today and tomorrow
so i will be acting chair and i stress
the acting
god bless her um she works very hard
so we're going to begin
this morning it is 901
i'd like to begin
um
with uh as is on your agenda house bill
142.
oh representative desimone do you have
let me get that to you
[Music]
in representative desimone i will take
oh
christine how are you going to get that
to me i'm going to send you an email so
you can read it from your computer
oh my goodness okay i'll try
christina
christina deyer
yes i'm sorry i'm running two meetings
at the same time so i apologize
okay this is representative
can you send a link to
representative grossman
yes absolutely i'll do that right now
carolina
yes
hi good morning do you um
i had requested i don't know if um karen
is on this call or if that was just her
that ducked off as i was coming in
um but are you getting the um blue sheet
okay so
they don't come in color to me
but you know what i mean the sign-ins
just the the forward against
uh yes
you are
wait a minute you mean that from the
public or from the committee
the public
okay good morning
i do not get them okay
good morning
good morning debra how are you i am well
thank you representative altschiller how
are you i'm good
i'd like to start this morning meeting
now by uh reading the script that we
were given
as acting chair of the children and
family law committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow
please note that there are no physical
locations for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
excuse me
and uh the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through electronic calendar
on the general court website
notice complies with house rule rsa
91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600
or email
legislative
services by um the email is hcs
leg
dot
state dot nh dot u s
um
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
christina dyer is the staff assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
we will also start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
thank you good morning members of
children and family law i recognize
representative alicea to take the roll
call
thank you vice chair testimony
uh representative all schiller
here
here and i am in my studio in exeter
are you alone
i'm alone my husband's in the house
though
i am
thank you
representative luiki
i am here i am at home um and i do have
representative long
representative rice has been excused
representative wazir
good morning um i am home with three of
thank you
representative
i am here in my home alone thank you
good morning i am here in room 210 to 11
thank you
and representative alicea i have a house
guest that's coming in and out and a
puppy
yes
thank you
good morning everyone um this morning
we're going to start with uh house bill
142.
um this is a bill that was brought to
you by me
so after this if anybody has any
questions
i can answer your questions but i will
not be asking any questions
[Music]
we do have
um
we do have one person to testify after
i open the bill
so with that i would like to open house
house bill 122 is relative
house bill 142 is relative to causes for
divorce
what we're doing is on uh roman numeral
roman numeral seven
um we were we are adding
and correcting
the verbiage of this bill so it will say
when either party
habitually abuses alcohol or drugs and
has been doing so for two or more years
i feel that this will clarify
um that cause of divorce more so
than what was already there
and with that um
to testimony
uh we have
um and i will i will open her in one
second
we have uh mindy green
last year decent money does she have a
testimony
i will get to that in one second i'm
trying to open her in having difficulty
christina i'm having trouble opening
okay are we looking for
mindy green is that right yes yes i see
her
but
my system won't allow me to open
good morning ms green can you
the screen if you can hear us you can
also press the space bar to speak
if you're having trouble muting
yes
good morning
good morning miss green how are you this
morning good i apologize i'm having
technical difficulties can you hear me
yes if you're on a second device oh
there you go perfect yes i apologize um
i greatly apologize for that i don't
know what the issue was my name is mindy
green i'm in derry new hampshire
thank you very much representatives for
allowing me to speak today
i've never done this before so you know
forgive me if it's um not exactly
uh the right thing but i can't hear is
to revise the uh the wording for a fault
divorce and my understanding was that
adding the sexual misconduct phrase
was also part of this bill
my understanding was that the law simply
the states the law right now as it is
that adultery can only occur between a
man and a woman
i'm talking to today because i'm going
through a divorce
and i begin a gay marriage and my wife
committed the adultery
when i submitted my testimony for the
hearing to the judge
it was thrown back because adultery in
the state of new hampshire is only
between a man and a woman
um we fought for marriage rights so
straight couples have the right to marry
and then
gay
people have the right to marry so we
have the right to marry but we do not
have the right to divorce in the same
manner i was thrown back all of my
exhibits
um and the lawyer on the opposing side
from concord was able to get lawyer fees
out of me when it's his client that did
the adultery
i find it completely discriminating
that we are allowed to marry but we are
not allowed to base our adultery
cause of divorce for adultery just
because
we are two women
when i talked about this to uh in the
hearing and to my lawyer to the judge
my the lawyer was very patronizing and
told me well that's the law you want to
do something about it i guess go to
legislation
well
here i am
um i don't know what i can do i'm hoping
that this bill with the sexual
misconduct phrase would allow me if this
became law
to resubmit my divorce claim on the
basis of adultery rounds with adultery
because i can use the sexual misconduct
it isn't unfair how far our gay rights
have come
and yet i am still discriminated against
in my law my divorce proceedings my
final hearing is not until june
i don't know if anything would happen in
a timeline where i can resubmit my claim
of adult trade rounds for adultery in my
divorce hearing
but if not and i unfortunately had to
pay fees which i did not think was fair
um i'm hoping that future
gay and lesbians that have any issues in
a marriage
adultery is adultery just like marriage
is marriage man to woman or woman to
woman or man to man
so
i may not be clear exactly what this
hearing is it seems like after the
opening of the bill that it's just to
change the wording
for the two years and that seems fine to
me makes the wording more clear so i
support that
bill that you're looking at today
um if anybody can help provide any
other information to me
as far as what i'm not reading correctly
if the sexual misconduct is already in
law i don't think it's already in law as
far as what i was looking at
so that's all i wanted to say um i
thought this was a proper uh place that
i can do some outreach i've emailed a
couple of representatives but i
understand people are busy i have not
gotten any personal responses except for
maybe one
um i'm trying to find anybody in
legislation that would help me
this is not right in the lgbq community
thank you very much for your time
thank you miss green do you have written
testimony that you can submit please
i i can do that yes
thank you and also i think that if you
hang on
uh the next person that i'm going to
call is attorney jay markell and he will
discuss the other portion of the bill
that you're talking about
um
to
remove certain words so that
um sexual misconduct of either party
which includes the following and it no
longer
specifies man woman
so i think if you listen to uh represent
uh two to
attorney jay markell it might help you
madam
chair and representative alessa this is
representative cody blander i have
pardon the interruption
um just wanted to let you know
i am present in my car on my way to
concord i apologize
because i had an appointment that i
needed
thank you representative uh you will be
marked present when you get here and i
forgot to ask does anybody have any
questions for
mindy green
um i i do
madam chair i put i raised my hand in
the chat where would you like us to
notify you that we have questions
no you did it correctly i'm new to this
so um i i am asking your indulgence so
ahead representative all chiller go
ahead with your question
uh
okay i'm unmuted again um thank you for
uh taking my question ms green
and um i'm wondering are you
are you aware at this time
problem that you have you are
experiencing right now within the
judicial system
is actually being addressed at the
supreme court right now um there is a
case that is going through the court um
that would address your issue and so
there is going to be a
um there will be a finding um probably
within the next few months that will
that will probably come out before any
legislation could finish winding its way
through
this process
thank you do you have information i can
research that case name or anything
thank you very much representative sure
sure yeah so it's there right now
excellent
thank you representative all chiller and
thank you miss green
uh the next person we have to speak is
attorney jay markell
he was
he will be able to help you to
understand this bill even further i
represent uh attorney markel are you
ready
yes
yes representative de simone i am go
ahead okay thank you for hearing me i'm
sorry for joining the meeting somewhat
late um
so
if i i came in on the tail end of that
and it was my understanding that in
support of this bill somebody who just
testified indicate that they were in a
same-sex marriage and that there was the
type of uh sexual misconduct described
which is described in house
uh 142.
um if somebody
uh
what i was basing what we were basing
this bill on was first of all not only
the traditional notions of what
constituted sexual misconduct was
but also on the way the new hampshire
supreme court had previously treated
claims
of what adultery was specifically
in the in the case of henry blanchflower
from 2003
uh
the court turned down the notion of
adulterous conduct when one of the
parties was engaged in basically a
same-sex same-sex sex practices okay in
other words what the new hampshire
supreme court said would adultery uh
gets its common ordinary um
interpretation which at that time
required sexual intercourse uh defined
as traditional heterosexual intercourse
between a man and a woman
um
just by way of uh just by way of trying
to clear some of this stuff up
last night i emailed a copy of a new
hampshire bar news article that i had
done uh which described more generally
this these issues uh
for the committee uh that was done i
think in november of last year regarding
this legislation
what you have here
is more generally is
bringing
same-sex couples and
i'm going to say traditional couples
heterosexual couples more in unity
because what it does is it gives them
mutuality and commonality of remedy
uh
what you have here is um
a situation where people who are
engaging in sex practices that do not
implicate uh sexual intercourse
nevertheless have the same remedies uh
so this is actually does
for one of a better term level the
playing field and try and provide true
sexual equality um because what it does
is it gives the commonality of remedy
because it applies not only to same-sex
couples but also applies to uh
traditional couples as well now what we
do here if you read it
we borrow from the felonious sexual
assault statute that already exists
the one difference here is is that as
you read it is is that there has to be
intentional touching uh which could be
reasonably construed for the purposes of
arousal or gratification now that's an
important protection because people who
have either a laying on of hands for
therapeutic reasons which could protect
doctors obstetricians gynecologists
proctologists and people like that are
doing that in the course of their
profession so this could not be
construed for that reason
so it re so it has a necessary
protection in it
um you know i'd be happy to entertain
any questions the committee may have
on this issue
thank you mr markell we do have one
question i'll get to that person
momentarily okay
and um
and that would be
um
representative long
okay yes representative how can i help
you
thank you madam chair
uh yeah attorney markle um
i mean it's not on the uh the same-sex
issue my question is
um
you know
i'm married for five years i've been
drunk and a drug addict for three
i'm in six months recovery
could they go back in
would that be grounds uh
with with this change of two years is it
i mean does this assume consecutive
years or current
well oh okay no i'm sorry yeah well it's
basically two years if i read this
correctly i think we have two years
together oh two or more years okay i see
uh now i just had to double check what
was written here it's two or more years
um it could be separate or it could be
uh
it could be departed that's that is and
that is left to the discretion of the
court and that's going to be able to re
reduce problems with offers of proof so
in your case
the issue i think is whether or not
you're trying to rehabilitate yourself
and you're falling back in there so
that's going to be up to a court side
uh i if i haven't answered your question
please let me know
no you have so it's so it's not
community
can you have a follow up
thank you
yeah thank you madam chair i do follow
up go ahead
so so it's not
um
it's not current and in a row
that's correct so uh my other my
follow-up is uh
um
i mean who verifies this what happens if
both parties are
having a drinking problem well then you
have yeah okay those are good questions
then what you have is the affirmative
defense of recrimination let me explain
uh
you have to be it's important to
remember
that uh to be able to prevail in a
fault-based divorce the other party has
to be blameless of any conduct that
would have taken place which also would
have given rise to a fault-based divorce
so in other words when you read a
divorce when you read rsa 458 7 and
you're looking at fault-based divorce it
basically says a divorce shall be
granted on these grounds to a party for
want of a better term uh who is
blameless it's innocent party is the way
i think it reads and that means you
haven't done anything wrong so in other
words if we go to court and
i say
uh you know you've been abusing alcohol
or drugs for the last two to
two of the last three years
and uh you say but judge
uh he she has been doing exactly the
same thing and you bring the evidence in
well that kind of cancels it out that's
that's in the law that's an affirmative
defense of recrimination
okay that's what it's called uh so you
can't provide you can't prevail on a
fork round that way now the reason it
says two or more years i think you can
fairly infer
um is is that people can have problems
in a marriage people can go through
rehabilitation in a marriage you know
but if it looks like the effort has
failed and this does not
one night of drinking or
you know
one night of drinking or even a problem
with drinking for a short period of time
you know this is going to be at the
discretion of the court as these cases
often are uh you know did they prove
their case is the question
so that's where i think you're kind of
at with this
um if i haven't answered anybody's
question
uh please continue to ask me i'll make
sure i can get it
mr markell will you take another
question
sure
representative grossman can you unmute
thank you madam chair for taking my
question
um so
i too have concerns regarding the um
the alcohol drug abuse section
what happens if someone so recovery and
sobriety are a very fluid situation what
happens if someone is
actively trying to get sober
relapses
where does that fall in here um
okay
very good question and that's really
going to be a matter for a court to
decide because that's going to be fact
specific what we're talking about here
is having the grounds to plead we the
the
basically this is somebody who's going
to be able to say
uh your honor this has been the problem
in the marriage this is what i think
caused the breakdown of the marriage and
then you plead your case okay and then
the court has to decide so in other
words and i have these cases uh where
somebody comes in and i have them where
somebody's been an alcoholic right now
as it stands you can't plead a drug
problem because we don't recognize that
under the law in new hampshire and i've
had those cases
uh
right now in re uh to be more specific i
have two of these cases right now just
like this okay somebody goes into rehab
somebody comes out they continue
drinking again so in other words that's
going to be part of the cause of action
that you plead it's going to be
but judge
uh
he she went into rehabilitation they
tried to clean themselves up but it
didn't work they're back to drinking
again you know over the last two years
he she
did this went into rehab
uh came out went back to drinking or
taking drugs again went into rehab went
back in and repeats his cycle has often
particularly with drugs which takes
place very commonly i've seen those
cases too
so that's the issue for a court to
decide
uh
that's fact specific
two years i think is enough of an
opportunity to be able to say you know
the marriage is damaged beyond repair
and this is the problem that we see in
the marriage so we've tried we've lived
with it for a while uh this kind of
that's that's how i see it um i
you know i think it improves the statute
particularly with adding the drugs
aspect to it because that's really
commonplace today
thank you mr markell will you take
another question yes i will
thank you um representative altschiller
you may ask your question
thank you madam chair and thank you
uh mr markell for taking my question um
you mentioned that you have two cases
ongoing right now
in your experience how many
divorces are found on fault grounds
well
that's fact specific um
i can't give you a definitive answer
other than to say cases plead okay which
is the important thing how they resolve
is something different so to directly
answer your question do we plead fault
grounds yes we plead fault grounds when
a the client thinks it's important and b
if it looks like there's a chance of
prevailing but given the fact that um
i would say better than 90 of the cases
that are filed resolve
uh
people may look at the fall grounds and
say well in the interest of settling the
case and getting other aspects that i
want uh i will dismiss on fault grounds
uh and they will just go for
irreconcilable differences but it's very
common practice to affirmatively plead
fault grounds in a petition or cross
petition for divorce in addition to
irreconcilable differences if you have
them
one of the less plagued grounds
interestingly enough which doesn't
figure in here is impotence uh i
actually have a case right now where
impotence is one of the four grounds
thank you mr markell representative
alterwood do you have a follow-up no i'm
i'm good thank you i will lower my hands
thank you
seeing none i will close the hearing on
house bill 142
and ask
mr markell to stay on the line
so once i introduce house bill 547
we can hear from um
mr markell and then we have other people
to testify so stay tuned
madam chair
representative petrino here yes
representative
i would just like to acknowledge my my
presence i apologize for being toddy i'm
in my home office alone
thank you representative i also see
representative smith
yes i'm sorry um i
had my date confused so i thought it was
9 30.
um
i am here with my three children and my
husband and my loud dogs but um
hopefully you won't hear any of them
because
my earphones are in
that's okay
welcome again representative alessia did
you
record representative belanger
did he did he just come in
yes
okay nope no ma'am i've been present
um since 9 uh 12. yeah
16. i apologize representative petrino
just uh signed in
okay um you can correct me if i'm wrong
a vice chair testimony
it's my understanding that until
they're
physically
um
at the meeting
that's the time that i need to put down
so initially i had
9 20 for representative blanchard
but it's now 9 37
so i just wanted to be sure you had him
so
uh 9 20 9 12 those are perfect
from representative belanger
thank you
madam chair
yes yes
um i
may
may i please read out our
after each of the bills how many people
have signed in and
i apologize you're correct thank you for
bringing it to my attention i just want
to make sure before we move on to the
next one so it doesn't get confusing
no you're absolutely correct um i i'll
read those out for you
i have the house testimony sheet for
house bill 142
we have eight in support and we had to
testify
we had zero opposed and zero neutral
thank you for bringing that to my
attention representative
i'm i'm new at this
no worries me too um quick question for
you you had just said eight in support
yes ma'am and i have a sheet here that
says 10 in support so is it possible
that two more people signed in or they
took their names off
it's possible that two more signed in
since this sheet was printed
so that's good for that for you
um chairwoman desimone um i did print
those um sheets for representative all
chiller after you were given yours so it
is possible so hers are a little more
recent
okay thank you anything else
representative all chiller
no no no worries because i also had one
testify but we ended up having two so
correct
right correct just make a note alright
so we'll confer
thank you thank you yeah
okay so uh we have closed the hearing on
um house bill 142 we will now
um
begin uh hearing testimony on house bill
and i will open the discussion
um
i'm sorry is uh representative gay
here
yes
representative gay if you can unmute
yes i have
there you go would you like to open
house bill 547
yes and i commend all of y'all for
dealing with such a difficult subject
all day long
all year both years long
now that i'm on health and human
services we have
similar concerns
house bill 547 is extremely simple
and if you had told me this three years
ago i wouldn't have believed that it was
necessary but since then i have learned
that some judges and when i say judges i
don't mean all i mean the ones who are
doing this
okay
uh i don't by my uh telling you that
things need to be improved
i do not intend it to mean criticism of
everybody in that category but
the serious
situation is that at least
at least some judges
are breaking rules
and uh
ignoring rsas and this one in particular
no evidentiary hearing was ever
permitted
to this parent
who had serious concerns
had documentation of abuse of her child
by her
assumed to be ex-spouse
was never permitted to
have the hearing
because the judge
i'm well i can't say why
but i do know that
she had been ordered to take her child
to
[Music]
a supervised visitation
with this
ex soon-to-be ex-spouse
and there was the person who was
supposed to supervise it had just been
stripped of her credentials for cause
and
if that wasn't bad enough the place that
they were supposed to meet had none of
the protections that are federal and
state for making it a safe place
there's quite a list of federal and
state requirements for safety
unfortunately that's probably another
bill
that uh has
i think you all have attempted to get it
to get it passed
for safe uh i can't remember the real
term but it's where you know children
can meet with
a spouse a parent
so she said i can't i can't bring my
child there it's dangerous
and all i can think is that was the
reason that the judge refused to give
her an evidentiary hearing
and instead
ultimately without ever hearing
for her
gave custody of her daughter
to this abusive parent that she had no
chance to show how dangerous he was
she had to give up everything and leave
the state with not much more than the
clothes on her back
so i don't know how many other people
have been
treated like this
but
i've had two people
uh suggest that it should be amended to
say
that equal this says you know that
excuse me
in any proceeding to determine parental
rights and responsibilities
each parent is entitled to at least
one hearing to present evidence and call
witnesses so two people have said one is
they ought to say they have equal number
of testimonies because
often the person has more money
can ask for more hearings and pay for
more
and the other person uh an attorney said
and no unsupervised visitation
until evidentiary hearing is held for
both parents
so that concludes my my testimony i
certainly hope that you can
help elaborate on the finer parts of the
law
thank you representative gage we have
representative vice chair does uh
representative gay have a written
testimony please
do you have written
representative
i have emailed y'all and if you if it
may make it easier i'll just email again
thank you can you specifically email it
to representative alastair
yes
thank you
thank you kindly
um the next person that we have uh to
testify
is uh aaron justina
um
good morning madam vice chair and
members of the committee my name is
aaron justina and i direct the domestic
violence advocacy project at new
hampshire legal assistance
for more than 20 years the domestic
project has been representing victims
and survivors of domestic violence
sexual assault and stalking in their
protective order cases as well as their
high lethality divorce and parenting
cases
i'm here today to testify in opposition
to house bill 547
i'd like to begin by mentioning that a
similar bill was proposed by
representative gay last session that was
house bill 1270
that bill was itled by this committee in
a unanimous 19-0 vote
house bill 547 seeks to correct a right
which is already afforded to every
litigant entering the family court
system namely the right to seek justice
this bill seeks to add a new paragraph
for under rsa 461a3
but if you look at the existing statute
namely paragraph two which reads
in cases where husband and wife or unwed
parents are living apart the court upon
petition of either party may make such
order as to parental rights and
responsibilities
and support of the children
as justice may require so upon petition
of either party means that one of the
parents makes a request to the court to
be heard on a particular issue
so once that happens the law goes on to
say that the court may make such order
as to parental rights and
responsibilities
in order for the court to make an order
a hearing must be held so to add a
fourth paragraph would be redundant and
is unnecessary
additionally the language of this bill
will cause confusion as it states each
parent is entitled to at least one
hearing so does that mean one hearing
per parent do the hearings happen
simultaneously where the opposing party
has an opportunity to question the other
party's witnesses and review evidence
or will the court need to schedule a
separate hearing to allow the other part
the other parent to
respond this bill is likely to lead to
confusion and is redundant of a right
already afforded to family court
litigants under the law therefore i
respectfully request this committee vote
in expedient to legislate thank you
thank you mr cena do you have written
testimony that you have submitted or
will submit
i have not submitted written testimony
if the committee would like to i i can
summarize the testimony i just gave
thank you we would appreciate it if you
could email it to representative alexeia
to be entered into the record
absolutely
i
i'm happy to answer um
thank you we have actually three
questions um representative long
can you unmute yourself and ask your
question
i can thank you madam chair um
the the bill uh so what you're claiming
is the bill is redundant when you uh
because it's allowed in 461-a colon
three two
correct and that's what it looks like
that i'm reading here correct yes
okay
you know since we're on these divorces
do you feel that if we're gonna change
uh you know if we're gonna accept bills
or change bills or propose bills
that in case in cases where husband and
wife language is there
uh
should we lose it use that uh you know
use this opportunity to fix that or is
that being taken care of in the spirit
in the supreme court
you mean um in the difference between a
divorce case um and then just a straight
parenting case well from a from a
same-sex married parent
uh both of us are parents to a child
yeah doesn't apply because it's we're
not husband and you know we're not
husband and wife
so
right so this is just in the parenting
statute so if it was um in the if there
was a divorce case with kids this would
apply as well okay great
yeah okay thanks
thank you representative uh the next
question is from uh representative
altschiller
thank you madam chair and thank you miss
miss justina for taking my question if i
if i understood your testimony correctly
um
it's yours is it your assertion that
this is a due process issue that's
already addressed in in the same statute
yes thank you for your question so i
just to be clear um at any point in the
process of filing a parenting petition
or a divorce petition there is already a
system in place for litigants to seek
relief at any point in the process there
are multiple hearing phases along the
way and there's nothing preventing
someone from
accessing the court system to get
justice so the due process issue is
okay thank you for the clarification
thank you for your question
thank you miss messina we have one more
question representative yokela can you
yes thank you um
i had a question about your statement
that there was
hearing based on
the
request of either party but it seemed to
me by the language that you read
that
they could request um
they could say that there is an issue
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
the court will grant a hearing to
uh
you know have those people submit
evidence and testimony et cetera et
cetera to that fact they
could they could the judge not just
decide
on the
um
the petition alone and not have a
hearing is that not the case
thank you for your question so
a party would
either petition the court through a
parenting petition or a divorce petition
or if the case is already opened they
could file a motion requesting any kind
of particular relief it is possible
that a judge would um
issue an order based on the pleadings
alone um it's less likely in my
experience um but even in that situation
even if the party filed a motion
and didn't agree with the judge's
decision there is an appeals process you
can request a hearing you can request a
motion for reconsideration there are
multiple steps along the way
that would allow for a hearing for a
party to be able to present their
evidence and present witnesses
and even at that point even after a
hearing if somebody doesn't like the
decision you can appeal all the way to
the supreme court so there is a process
in place to be heard um so for those
reasons and as well as the language in
existing statute
this bill really is not necessary um i
can't speak to the particular facts of
the case that representative gay
presented
but i can say in my experience that
these cases tend to drag on quite long
in family court because parties are
always getting hearings
anyone can request one at any time and
it may not be scheduled in a timely
manner but one will be scheduled and the
parties will be heard
do you have a follow-up representative
yokela
yes thank you
um
you said that there was um an ability to
appeal
and
to question essentially the ruling and
do those appeals
um
are is it an option for the judge to
allow
um so it's really i would say it's more
a litigant's option um this
system is in place
for the public
so
i'll give an example uh you have a
temporary hearing
and the parties have a temporary hearing
and at the end of the temporary hearing
the judge decides that
both parties should be able to spend
time with the kiddo despite there being
evidence of abuse
so
the victim in that case obviously being
concerned for the safety of the kiddos
and the safety of herself
disagrees with the judge's decision
maybe she presented evidence maybe the
judge misconstrued the law
at which point she can file a motion for
reconsideration
and saying all of the reasons why she
disagrees and why the judge got it wrong
if the judge
does not
agree at that point there are further
levels of appeal
including going up to the new hampshire
sure one more
thank you
so what you're saying is that you can
request an appeal but it doesn't need to
be it doesn't necessarily need to be
granted or a hearing doesn't need to be
scheduled for any of those appeals they
could all just be denied without a
hearing is what you're saying if i'm
understanding
so that's i'm
not exactly right so if somebody
files
an emotion to reconsider a judge's order
you are correct a judge could say
that there's not going to be a hearing
on that issue i'm denying your motion
for reconsideration at which point you
have further appeal options and likely
at that point there would be some kind
of hearing held
um
but that's a little bit different than
what this law is stating or what this
bill is requesting that anyone can
request a hearing at any time that is
already in place
um it
so
it's it's confusing because it's really
two separate issues whether you're
appealing an issue or whether you're
requesting relief for a particular legal
issue or you're seeking a particular
legal outcome
in which case that's how the family
court is designed to allow litigants to
do that and to have the opportunity to
be heard
thank you
thank you for your questions
thank you very much miss messina um
mr markell do you have we have about
three minutes before our next bill do
you have any input
okay thank you uh thank you madam vice
chair the situation here as i see it is
whether or not these your you have a
right
uh in family court as you do in
virtually every court at least in the
state of new hampshire for notice an
opportunity to be heard what you have
being heard is fully heard that could
mean a hearing and that can mean a right
to present evidence and witnesses
the questions are and by the way that's
i think already enshrined in new
hampshire case law i'm thinking of
cossack off the top of my head but i
could be wrong on the site however the
question is whether or not this is
self-executing
[Music]
and whether this is self-executing uh is
a decision the kid the committee has to
make so
if a person requests a hearing and it's
denied then i think you probably have a
very good um
uh you may have a very good uh
denial of due process issue there under
the 14th amendment and under the new
hampshire constitution as well
so that's something this committee is
going to have to decide i think
um
the other thing is just
speaking as a practical matter
appeals are very expensive tedious and
time consuming and not everybody can do
it either on a self-represented basis
or certainly through an attorney um
that's just my brief take on it so it's
a decision the committee makes
thank you mr markell uh representative
belanger do you have a question you can
unmute
uh thank you madam chair and i
appreciate it um my question is to the
previous speaker not
mr markell
if you can
so i myself am going through family
court and if if i understand this
correctly
the
appeal process
um
is
is is can be lengthy so
when you
when you appeal
the motion to reconsider
is denied you can appeal to the next uh
to the next court correct
yes this is um aaron justina yes that is
correct
uh follow-up
certainly one follow-up
so if i can
appeal that decision
um
what do you have a percentage of cases
is there excuse me is there data
that supports how many cases
are denied upon that
appeal
and
is there um in family court
is there a requirement that there is a
always at least
one hearing
so there's always going to be one
hearing i'll adjust your second um
question first there's always going to
be one hearing in family court if the
party's at least one hearing because
that's just the nature of how family
court is designed
assuming the parties don't wish to
settle
the case and want to proceed on a
litigation track there's going to be
first appearance
and then there may be a case manager
conference and then if the case is not
settling you're going to a temporary
hearing you're going to get that
temporary hearing and then if the case
is not settled at that point then you're
going to have a pre-trial conference and
then after that you're gonna have a
final hearing that's the general track
that litigated and contested cases take
that's the basic track so in addition to
that at any point someone could request
a review hearing
um
you know every three months every six
months if the case is going on and on um
but
everybody is going to get the temporary
hearing possibly the pre-trial
conference and the final hearing
thank you
madam chair uh no follow-up
thank you representative
um
any further questions from any of the
i will read the
remote testify sheet
we have 21 in support
we have one in opposition
zero neutral and we had three people
testify
and with that i will close the hearing
um during this hearing uh my video was
turned off by the host so i don't know i
i probably didn't shave too close this
morning but
okay christina did we shut um
representative long's handsome face off
no i didn't it says it says you connect
you cannot start your video because the
host has stopped it
well there you go
okay very good thanks sorry about that
i'm not sure what happened
thank you representative long for
bringing that to our attention
and with that we will open a hearing on
house bill 139
and i will ask representative
yo keller to unmute himself and
introduce his bill
thank you
madam chair and
members of the committee
i am here today to introduce hb 139
relative to uh
submission of evidence in divorce
proceedings
come back again
i it
was
originally i think introduced back in
or something like that and passed this
committee and got changed in the
senate and
in the committee of conference died and
then last year there was some
some minor alterations um
and ended up not not passing so i have
submitted again today and the main gist
of the bill is to
allow
for at least five days of
uh
that evidence being submitted in divorce
proceedings be submitted at least five
days prior to the hearing so that people
have an opportunity to um
gather evidence to
support their defense so that they are
not ambushed at the last second with you
know hundreds of
pages of
evidence that they
are
address in the hearing
and the amendment last time was to allow
for
in addition to
de minimis evidence
also to
allow an exception to
a requested
continuance um if such evidence was not
available to the party submitting the
evidence pre the um five days prior to
the hearing so that
any activities or evidence of activities
that happened during that five
days prior or it wasn't just available
for
any other reasons so let's say you know
what you didn't get it
uh in the mail from you know the irs or
whatever until the day before the
hearing and you want to submit that
and uh so what the the point of this
bill is is to allow for an automatic
continuance if you didn't get those fi
that evidence in that five day window
so that you have an opportunity to look
over it
and
if the the court denies that
that they
write down why they're denying it so
that you have the reasons that you can
appeal based on
so i hope you will support this and i'm
representative ultra fault shiller you
can
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative yokela for taking my
question
um you just mentioned in your testimony
that the in the
inspiration for doing this if i
understand you was to
um to make sure that everyone gets all
of the information they need ahead of
time
before a hearing
so that they aren't ambushed i think you
but right now um
i believe the time frame is 10 days your
this bill would shorten it to five days
um but there's nothing
here that stops somebody who doesn't
abide by
any deadline 10 days 12 days 5 days it
doesn't
it doesn't stop them and there's no
penalty for showing up to court on your
court date with a stack of documents yay
high
and then
force
the other party into making a decision
as to whether to continue
um because
they have waited for months and months
and months for a hearing or
in continuing the moment or wait yet
another 90 days
for
some relief and it seems that this would
really negatively impact
um
victims who are
you know who are low-income
members of our community um because it
would it just
it puts them between a rock and a hard
place anyway
um
and i feel like
in cases of alimony and child support
that this is an opportunity it's a wedge
for abusers to be able to
manipulate that system do you have a
question representative
is there
so my question my question is was this
part did you consider this
when you wrote this and did you have an
intention or an amendment forthcoming
thank you for the question so
as you as you stated um there is
currently court rules that require
them to submit it even even prior to the
five days so
so
if
the problem is that exactly as you
stated that if people don't abide by
that currently there is no
punishment necessarily given by the
judge
i mean it's definitely within their
prerogative because they're
not abiding by court rules but it
doesn't necessarily
give any
uh
there is no definitely no punishment
automatic uh in that case and it's
potentially possible that the judge
could wave
all uh waive that rule and not put any
uh
requirement or grant any recess and
insist that the hearing go on at that
point and so i think that this bill
actually says okay if you've broke the
rule so much that you're all the way
down to five days
and you're giving that testimony or that
that submitting that evidence at that
time
i want to give the person
um that is being essentially ambushed
yes um
the opportunity that they're not
currently given
necessarily by the court to
to um continue so i think that this is
bill is actually
increasing the opportunity and
increasing the rights for the person
being ambushed and not
um reducing their rights
i think it's putting you know those that
uh
kind of a stop gap in between and saying
okay the judge can can waive it if it
was six days they can waive their court
rules
but if it's four days they really need
to give the option to that the person uh
to
continue the hearing if they need time
to prepare their defense or
and so i think this is actually helping
not
limiting it even further but thank you
thank you representative all chiller we
have one more question representative
belanger
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
representative yokela for bringing this
forward
um i'm not sure if you're familiar with
the court process but um
when filing an initial motion for any
court proceeding
is there a
is there a wait time or an expected
response requirement
before the court can move forward with
making a motion
excuse me making a decision on that
motion
i'm not sure that i am the best person
to answer that question no okay follow
up madam chair
follow-up
so um
and i do have a question here so i
apologize and i will keep this part
brief but yes there is when you file an
initial motion there is a respect of 10
days that the other party
may
before a court may make a decision on
the original motion the other party has
at least 10 days before the court can
make that decision so
if i understand your bill correctly this
that is essentially what this is doing
um when submitting evidence into court
giving them a five or ten day grace
period
for
responding to the evidence presented to
the
court thank you
for the question
i'm not sure that that was a question
but i will i will address it
anyways thank you um i think that so
this is only for
um not necessarily for um
motions this is for in in preparation
for a hearing and so it's possible that
you could submit a motion you know
outside of a hearing but prior to a
hearing
one sure
okay sorry so yes it was a question i
was asking if your bill
pertaining to hearings
um
is essentially the same is what you're
trying to accomplish um with the 10-day
thank you
for the clarification
so
there are rules that say that
you're supposed to have just like in the
um 10 days to respond to emotion you're
supposed to submit um your evidence 10
days prior to the hearing that you're
going to be submitting to the hearing
but that is not always followed and the
judge doesn't always
give the opportunity for
the respondent to be able to adequately
adequately prepare to
address those that evidence and so this
is providing the opportunity
for that person to
[Music]
have some relief and say i
need time to prepare
there's a lot of evidence that i am not
that i haven't haven't had time to
prepare and let's say i'm a pro se
litigant and so
i need as much time as i can but
the the court
is required to have that continuance
within
the 90 days and so it's not going to be
pushed out at least 90 days it has to be
happening
um
within 90 days so i don't think that
it's going to
push the
hearing out
super far it will just give the it's
kind of a balance between
um originally it was um
the continuance would be not more than
30 days but the court
requested that it be 90 days so that
they have time to schedule it and so
and and
not be bogged down so i don't think that
is gonna
um
i don't think that it is exactly what
you're asking
but i think it's just
them it's meant to give a stop gap and
say this person needs these right this
right to prepare for their their
hearing
but thank you for the question
uh thank you for answering the question
thank you we have one more question
would you be willing to take that
question
absolutely
representative long go ahead thank you
madam chair with respect to the uh
with respect to the court
um
basis for its you know document that the
basis for its finding could it could
that basis be uh
the minimum
nature
thank you
yes i think that is so yes it could be
de minimis and say you know this is the
reason why and then you would be able to
appeal and say hey it's not the minimus
for these xyz reasons and therefore
have a motion for uh be able to you know
logically argue why why the continuance
should have been granted and that they
have been you know
this this is a miscarriage of justice
essentially
the main reason for having it written is
so that you have uh something to base
your appeal on
i think okay so follow up for me uh
madam chair
certainly
so
so the um the document can just read the
uh in nature and that's that's that's
the judge's um
document for the basis of his finding
that then that's that's sad that the
year this bill is okay with
thank you we now have uh aaron jacina to
testify
can you unmute yourself please miss
justina
yes thank you madam vice chair
um so again my name is aaron jusina and
i direct the domestic violence advocacy
project at new hampshire legal
assistance and i'm here today to testify
in opposition to house bill 147.
as representative yokela mentioned there
was an identical or near identical bill
proposed last session that was house
bill 1103
and this committee voted to itl that
bill
um so while this bill is well intended
and seeks to level the playing field for
litigants uh there would be unintended
consequences as uh representative alt
shiller uh mentioned
so if you're thinking about two parties
that are scheduled for
let's say a temporary hearing
and
one party
is a victim of domestic violence the
other party is her abuser
um he reads this law and says okay well
i know how i'm going to continue abusing
her and through the court system can't
do it in person anymore so i'm going to
abuse her through the court system so
i've been holding on to this stack of
financial records
and i'm going to show up to the hearing
and i'm unrepresented
so the court is really going to give me
some extra leeway
but i'm going to show up for this
hearing with my stack of financial
documents because i know she's seeking
alimony and child support
so she's not going to have time to
review any of these records
so
as representative all chiller said
you're really stuck between a rock and a
hard place at that point
because the victim shows up to court
most likely also unrepresented and is
just given this stack of financial
records and you're not going to be able
to go through those and digest those
records um five minutes before a hearing
you're certainly not going to be able to
run a child support calculation or
figure out what a temporary alimony
award should be
um so then you're faced with the fact of
okay well i could just go with what i
prepared um and ignore what was just
handed to me or take his word for it
or i can request a continuance which is
likely going to be granted if this
bill were to become law
and now we're looking at a period of not
more than 90 days
so even if you go out the three months
that means for those three months that
victim is potentially without child
support that victim is potentially
without alimony so she's not able to pay
her rent she may not be able to pay for
her car she's not able to take care of
her kids and this is all intentional
um
from the abuser uh and i do also want to
point out that because we're in covid 19
right now we're dealing with coping 19
the court has issued emergency orders
which allows them to extend certain
deadlines so right now we're talking
about 90 days but
for however long these emergency court
orders in effect those that 90 days
could be out the window and we don't
know how long that will be so she may
not get a hearing now for six months and
that's far too long for a low income
person or any person
to have to go without some sort of
financial relief
so that's my concern with the 90 days
but then there are other practical
considerations related to this bill
this bill is seeking to set evidence
requirements in the divorce statute but
it is not addressing
um
evidence requirements under 461a which
is the parental rights and
responsibility statute
um it doesn't address what happens in
those emergency type cases
where someone files an ex parte motion
the court has to
have a hearing on those cases within 30
days
but the respondent has a right to
request a hearing within five days so a
hearing could be scheduled within two
days
so how does this
uh bill interact with
those requirements that are already in
place it also would
trump
a number of family court rules which are
already in place related to
submission of evidence prior to hearings
so for those reasons i respectfully
request this committee vote in expedient
to legislate and i'm happy to take any
representative alice saying do you have
okay can you hear me now
yes ma'am go ahead
it's not a question it's just a
statement for the record um the last
speaker aaron justina at the very
beginning
beginning of the testimony for
139 she stayed at 547
but she did speak on
but this one was 139 so i just wanted to
say thank you
i apologize for that it's okay
representative was the year did you have
thank you
seeing none
of the chairs
do simone my apologies you do have
several people with their hands raised
in the attendance right
right
um one that had um
written in to to request to testify if
you wouldn't mind right that's what i
was going to do now
another representative raised his hand
but he took it down okay so
in the attendees list
i see a uh
paula
uh
werma
palawarma
can you unmute yourself
we'll go on to the next person and come
back to miss werma
we have a cat's cruise on
would you like to testify
can you hear me
yes we can
do you want to testify i sure do
my name is alice giordano and i am
appalled at some of the things that i
heard earlier i have been raising my
hand since the beginning of 139
um the gross misrepresentation that i've
heard in what's really going on in the
family courts right now is baffling
let's i know that you've passed 139 so
i'll be brief i do not have any formal
statement i just actually learned of
these bills uh this morning
um in terms of evidentiary hearings
there was a speaker he's absolutely
right that is the most fundamental due
process right afforded to every american
citizen in the united states in a court
of law
unfortunately in the state of new
hampshire
the family court judges have decided on
their own that that due process right is
an option
and if you and if you want to take
what's on paper and what's really going
on in the courts
the difference is mind-blowing it should
shock the conscience
you have family court judges that are
denying
multiple requests people begging for
evidentiary hearings
and the courts are waving their magic
wand
their judiciary magic wand in a court
system that is so unchecked and
unbridled that there are crimes literal
crimes and i'm not a crackbot i have a
background i was a reporter for the
national press my child actually
attended school with aaron gezina
she knows what's going on in the courts
she certainly knows that there's
problems with due process in my case
i had four separate motions for an
evidentiary hearing denied you can look
at my case the court the judge even
quoted himself i'm not interested in
hearing any evidence
you'll be hearing later in the day about
what they're really interested in what
they're really interested in in this is
this thing called reunification therapy
that is lining the pockets excuse me all
the appointees excuse me
excuse me we're um hearing testimony on
um house bill 139 if you want to talk
about reunification you're going to have
to wait until that bill comes before us
so do you have any further comments on
house bill 139 yes yes yes i do
thank you i'll give you another minute
or so thank you
this bill is critical to pass because
the problem is
if it's not explicit
then the judges aren't going to do it
and sadly in the state of new hampshire
you're going to start needing to spell
out every little right in writing
and and by the way this idea that you
can appeal is is just nonsense
the only appeal process in the state of
new hampshire unlike other states is in
fact the new hampshire state supreme
court so the only bite of the apple that
families have
at getting evidence
into the court system
is in fact through the due process of
the right to submit evidence which is
being denied repeatedly and grossly
it's rampant it's a rampant problem
there are there are cases i know of a
case
where the woman showed up with all her
her expert witnesses and the judge won't
even let him in
they are they are grossly denying due
process i i i
urge this committee to look further into
this matter i'm happy i'm an open book i
know many many parents who will who will
share their records with you to show we
even have it in writing that these
judges are denying
our right our most fundamental right
could you imagine being accused of
murder
and you go to trial the judge says yeah
i don't want to hear any evidence i'm
just going to make up my own mind and
that's exactly what's happening in the
court system in the state of new
hampshire thank you so much for
listening to me
thank you ma'am do you have written
testimony that you can submit to the um
committee
i sure do
thank you would you please email that to
representative caroletta alicea i'd be
happy to thank you kindly have a great
day you too
seeing none i'll ask uh paula wormaid to
okay i'll ask um
mr markell if he would like to testify
thank you thank you madam chair
uh yeah the situation what you really
have here is i think you're talking
about abusive discovery practices and
i would agree with a prior test a prior
witness that they unfortunately can be
rampant but i'm not sure that this bill
is the way to do it let me explain
uh when you're talking about things like
submission of exhibits and
courts
issue scheduling orders
uh scheduling orders are the timing and
sequence of discovery dude from
hello
hi can you hold on for a moment we have
somebody else anybody there
hello
go ahead mr marquel thank you
typically you have what are called
scheduling uh
typically when you have temporary
hearings uh
typically courts will do what they're
called is jointly
is uh
temporary hearings and scheduling
conference hearings and this is typical
and this is typically where courts
listen to the parties try to determine
what the issues are in the case
uh and then issue discovery deadlines
and then also issue usually timing and
sequence of exhibits uh and things like
that uh typically they're adhered to
what this bill i think is well
intentioned but it tries to
micromanage a court's docket reports
typically are able to manage their own
dockets
so uh what you have here is if and the
other thing is
excuse me
i i just want to talk to miss wormy okay
can you hear me
she's obviously having technical
difficulties i'm going to mute her again
and you can go ahead mr markell thank
you madam uh so what typically happens
is this and i i think what this bill is
well intentioned but what i'm hearing
here is is that the committee uh is
probably maybe asking itself
what is the tru what is the trial
process like and this is an attempt to
manage the trial scheduling process
which is typically
when it's done correctly
is done by the court itself it manages
the case from beginning to end so back
to the scheduling conference order you
can typically find them online on the
judicial website and you fill them in
and you submit them to the court or the
court administers its adminis admits its
own so when you look at you'll also find
the courts will include timing and
sequence of discovery and the court
frequently will issue
an order for the timing and exchange of
exhibits so the parties are to exchange
an exhibit by a certain date number one
and if they don't then then the and if
somebody tries to pay fast and loose
with the timing and sequence and
exchange of exhibits and the filing of
exhibits with the court the remedy can
be frequently a
motion in lemony which means that's a
gatekeeping motion which says judge due
to certain prejudice that i'm seeing uh
this person submitted these exhibits
late and now i'm prejudiced in my
ability to pre to uh present my case
because because because because they
were late because they result uh because
they were the result of issues that were
either not discussed or previously
discussed or not exchanged timely my
prejudice is thus and such and such and
such and such so then the court looks at
it and uh the court decides on the
motion whether or not there's prejudice
to the other party's case so in other
words you could actually be within
assuming the bill within that five days
but if there's no prejudice to the
person's case
then it really shouldn't matter
and this is typically the way the new
hampshire supreme court is going to look
at it since courts generally are
managing their own trial dockets when
you go up on appeal with submission of
evidence then the court on appeal is
going to look at whether or not it
constituted an unsustainable exercise of
discretion and within that unsustainable
exercise of discretion the new hampshire
supreme court would look at it and say
okay was there an objective basis in
fact or law for the ruling below
which said well okay the court decided
this and decided this and there was a
basis for it that being the case the
ruling would be affirmed uh
and when you're dealing with the
unsustainable exercise of discretion by
way of further submitting this to you
the question is whether or not you had
any prejudice to your case
so if somebody walks in with a stack of
documents that i heard uh mention you
know the morning of trial
you know well your honor uh
you know just going through this i'm
looking at this and i'm prejudiced and
if you have a a a good judge and this
stuff is all relevant then the judge is
going to say that's not coming in
okay
uh
you know i'm gonna you know and remember
motions can be made
written motions have a 10-day threshold
as a general's general rule but courts
can entertain oral emotions made right
on the spot so
what we're doing here is that we're
looking to manage the court's docket
um and manage the courts and manage the
courts daca then which has traditionally
been an area of regulation by the for
the court
i'd be happy to entertain and offer any
experience i have to the committee so
the committee can further study this
bill or the committee can make a
decision on it because this is the kind
of thing that i think requires somebody
with
some knowledge a trial
how the system is managed uh judicial
experience case management and so forth
so taken in isolation i don't see where
it helps no matter how well but i get
how well intentioned it is and i get the
the frustration in it i certainly can
see that um if there are any questions
i'm happy to answer
thank you mr markell i currently do not
see any questions so we'll try
uh to
bring in uh mrs miss murmur again
okay thank you
yeah can you hear me this time we can
hear you would you like to testify on
uh house bill 139
uh no i didn't want to testify on 139 i
wanted to testify on 5 47.
i just and i'm also trying to sign up
to speak on 556 577 and 548 and the
website
is not giving me the option to to uh
sign up to testify i apologize uh we
have concluded 547 so if you have
written testimony would you please
submit it
to
the committee
specifically use the
email address of representative carolina
alessia who was our ho our committee
clerk would you
be amenable to do that
uh yes i sent everything yesterday to
the committee uh email address but i
will resubmit it to uh
representative alessia
thank you kindly uh although you are not
signed up you said uh i will keep you in
mind when we get to the next few bills
and call on you to testify is that okay
with you
that is fine
thank you kind
i'm going to mute you right now but we
next i have a
uh
rich
richard head
richard would you like to testify on uh
house bill 139
i would um thank you madam chair for the
record my name is richard head i'm the
government affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch i do it before i testify
though i do have a question regarding
the registration because i did register
yesterday for
um the last bill 547 this one and the
next three
and that appears not to have made it to
your
to your list
so
i'll keep you in mind as we get to those
bills please stay tuned
thank you
and
i've had a couple issues with the
registration where i've registered and
it's not made the list but thank you for
the consideration
um again my name is richard head
testifying on house bill 139
we do have uh it and we're testifying
for information we do have some concerns
though with this bill it does create
direct conflicts with existing court
rules
uh in the timing of of evidence
evidentiary disclosure
as attorney markell had mentioned there
are currently rules that set up
deadlines um within the court process
uh final pre-trials are scheduled where
witness and exhibit lists are to be
exchanged
this bill would conflict with existing
court rules
and in in general as as you would
have probably heard in in other years
you know there are concerns
with
legislating court rules we do have
a rules committee in which two
legislators sit a senator and a
representative
and really if there are
rule changes that
legislators are interested in presenting
it's really through that rules committee
that court rules are established so
things that
set deadlines within the court system
for
exhibits witnesses things like that are
are really within the purview of the
court rules process
um but we do have of some significant
concerns relative to conflicts as to
which
would apply a statute or a rule
and this would create some some direct
conflicts with existing rules
and as you also heard from a prior
speaker you know once you set a rule
like this it can be then used
to manipulate the process
and we would have some concerns about
that
where
an exhibit or evidence may be
delayed deliberately by a party
in order to effect a delay of proceeding
so with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions
and i appreciate your time today thank
you
thank you representative long you have a
question
thank you madam chair uh
thank you uh mr head
um
i mean we're here in testimony and we've
heard testimony and
other uh
um
you know and on other bills with respect
to the judges not allowing
um
do you have a percentage or an estimate
has to
how many
um how many of these requests are denied
so not something that would be tracked
specifically as as you can imagine you
know
these are very very busy
court
so the
the
and evidence is
is being you know evidentiary
admission is are being asked all the
time you know you get it within the
context of the precise rules
or you get people who show up and for
the first time at a at a final hearing
are coming in with with various
pieces of evidence or witnesses
that you know are not within
the way the court had laid out the case
so those are you know those can be
denied they can be granted depending on
the circumstances a great deal of
discretion
is afforded
because you really have to take into
consideration the nature of the evidence
when it was produced
what is the
what is the schedule that all the
parties are required to abide by that
was set by the court
how often have there been violations of
that
so the short answer to your question is
we do not track individual
evidentiary decisions
on on each case
just by sheer volume and
the speed at which these decisions are
being made
but
if evidence is being presented within
the structuring conference order the
presentation of witnesses and exhibits
and they're appropriately before the
court they're typically heard
go ahead
thank you i yeah it would be very
helpful to this committee because as you
hear
in testimony
it is never
allowed
i you know we have people saying that
saying that it
they are never allowed so
it would help me in determining some
determining some of this
um what
what it you know
i i gotta weigh both sides i got
constituents coming to testify saying
it never happens
and and then i've got the court the
judicial branch saying
well yeah you know what happens
sometimes and but i'm not sure how often
uh so it really would be helpful to try
to get that balance um and i you know i
understand that it's short notice for
you to have the answer today but
that that would be nice to know
um that there are
there are predominantly uh
you know uh
uh
emotions being heard
so thank you
and and thank you for that i to the
extent we can drill down and certainly
you know we just simply don't have
evidentiary decision tracking
capacity
our system just simply doesn't do that
i would i would significantly dispute
that never happened certainly people are
upset at times with decisions being made
by
courts and
may extrapolate out from that that their
experience is the way
the courts always act
which is not correct we you know
very very much follow the court the
rules the procedures that are set out
and the orders that are issued in each
case in terms of procedure and those are
followed and evidence is being presented
every day in family court witnesses are
being heard every day in family court
and
you know the normal practice and
procedure
applies there are circumstances where
somebody believes they're being treated
unfairly when in fact you know they the
rules
were not being followed and
you know it just happens sometimes um
and
into you those individual cases
um are not representative of all of the
cases really each circumstance is very
fact specific and very timing specific
in each one of those circumstances has
thank you mr head uh
any further questions from mr head
representative lewicki uh madame chad
this is more of a point of information
but uh ms wermer sent us testimony on
547 and as part of that she included the
form which includes scheduling and a
whole lot of other stuff and i think
that would be very informative to the
committee
so it has come to my attention obviously
that
some of the people who are attendees
that would like
to testify on certain bills
are not on my list
for whatever reason their testimony and
your testimony is very important to all
of us
please if you choose to
testify on a particular bill and i do
not call your name please raise your
hand and i will call on you
we cannot make proper
uh decisions on any bill without hearing
all sides of the testimony so i ask you
to indulge me and please raise your hand
if we're on a particular bill and you
would like to testify you cannot ask
questions again but you can and are
hopefully going to testify and please
always remember to submit written
testimony for our records so we can go
over it when we
um exec these bills i want to thank you
and with that i will close question
madam chair with respect to what you
said i'm sorry representative long go
ahead uh yeah i
i mean with respect to the rule reading
the covet 19 if people aren't able to
um testify
uh then
we would have to redo this um and my
understanding is that there were people
that were signed up to testify that
didn't testify
um so i don't know if if i just want to
make sure we're on the up and up
uh when the public's saying that they
can't testify
uh
you know the emergency order says with
respect to this remote that we would
redo it um so i don't know if mr dyer
can just get that clarification for us
thank you christina can you clarify that
i know she's on another working on
another committee as well
it was my mistake
not to
hear those
because they're not on my list
uh for house bill 139 i had
only one person signed up
to testify
on house bill 547 i only had one person
signed up
to testify
on house bill 142 i only had one person
signed up to testify i understand that
people's names are in
the attendees list
but i cannot
there's no way for me to discern
what bill they want to testify on or not
i'm trying my best
and i do agree that their testimony is
extremely important and they do have a
right to testify but they did not sign
up prior to
this morning
as soon as i can get in touch with um
christina
i will have her discuss that for you
does that work for you representative
long yeah that's fine it just seems like
there's mis
you know
yeah there's miscommunication
it's internal is what i'm saying it's
internal so it's not that they can't
uh
they can't get into testifying
they can get in to testify they just
haven't
signed up right
so people
people out there need to know that they
need to sign up
in order to
be on my list
to testify
uh and i'll talk with christina and have
her uh discuss that with you after
representative ocala
yes um so normally at the end after we
do all of the people that signed up
they they move the chair moves on to
hear people that didn't sign up but are
raising their hand and i think that was
the step that might have been missed in
earlier ones and that was the cause of
the frustration so as long as we're
doing that going forward i think the
issue will be resolved thank you i stand
corrected
thank you uh in that case we will move
on
to
house bill
state ordered counseling and i'll ask
representative betty gay to unmet uh
unmute herself
and
she can introduce her bill
okay thank you very much are you ready
yet
thank you uh madam chairman for
dealing with the difficult situation i
very much appreciate your including uh
the people who had signed who did not
know how to sign up and then couldn't
uh so thank you very much for uh
whoops
i'm sorry representative gay i excellent
accidentally muted you please go on
yes you are okay
uh yes i was thanking you um
this 556
was passed last year and it passed it
was the second bill we heard on the very
last day we met
in march and so it never made it to the
senate
uh this is probably the most all i think
all my bills will serve
victims of domestic abuse this is
probably the most
important one
it doesn't say reunification therapy
because
uh you could do the same therapy and
call it something else the important
thing is that any any kind of counseling
that the state uh orders should be one
that is legitimate that has training
that has certification that has a
certified uh cpt uh trying to remember
what cpt means but all your medical
procedures have a procedure name
let's see
if all parties
if all let's see
child welfare services i'm so sorry i'm
so nervous because this is so important
to me nothing in this chapter and any
other provision of law shall permit a
state agency including the state courts
or a public or private provider acting
on behalf of a state agency to require
individuals to participate in counseling
that has no cpt medical code and thus is
not a recognized form of mental health
treatment nor eligible for insurance
reimbursements so the victims of abuse
suffer in two ways number one there's an
rsa that says you are not the state does
not force you to be with your abuser
but this does
uh they'll order what they call
reunification therapy which sounds great
until you find out it's part of this
not our beloved gardener but uh a
richard gardner who in 1985
convinced an awful lot of people in
court to adopt this really sick theory
that has been totally debunked
repeatedly by professional child
psychologists
children who are abused do not make up
stories
parents may try to get kids to say
things
but if some a genuine counselor can talk
with that child
if they start describing
uh
well sexual abuse is one of the most
awful ones and unfortunately it really
happens and some people have a hard time
accepting that parents can do
something so awful to their children but
they do
and when children can account that they
didn't make it up
um so that is very totally accepted
among professionals
counselors
toxicologists
in not only our country this sick theory
that
child abuse
of that the parent who reports abuse
is the cause
and therefore
the children aren't believed
the parents of
asking for help with the courts are not
believed are there blamed this is what
the worst they're blamed for the child
having a bad uh relationship with the
abusive parent and sadly this sick
theory has spread to england
and has spread to australia i have
listened online i've listened to
professional discussions
where some people are hoping that it's
going away well it hadn't gone away and
it's alive and well here i hope to gosh
that it's not prevalent in the state of
new hampshire but it certainly is
prevalent in the courts that people that
i have been trying to help have had to
endure
um let's see um so they they suffer both
ways one is that they're forced to be
with the abuser and the other horrible
thing is
they are stripped penniless because this
is not a professional accepted form of
counseling
insurance doesn't cover it but the women
mostly it's women but we know there are
cases of men being in abusive situations
who are working desperately to protect
their children
they are told
if you fight this and if you don't do
participate and bring your child to this
this
therapy
we're going to give we're going to give
custody of these children
to the abuser and that is part of the
plan that is in writing and uh i will
send you the link so if you find
whatever time you find
you can uh see it in
in
on testimony
uh where one of the uh richard dakoti is
a famous attorney not famous here but in
pennsylvania and louisiana uh and he is
famous for his writings about dealing
with abuse in court and he got one of
the followers
to spill the beans in court i shouldn't
use such a cutesy term but he really
spelled it out because this gardener guy
really believed in sex with children and
then he derived this and a whole lot of
abusers loved his his theories about oh
it's always the protective parents fault
that this child doesn't want to be with
the abusive parent
and it's because because the
parent who reported it obviously is a
bad parent then custody goes to the
abuser and sadly that's happening here
and um
so they get hurt twice oh some women i
know and so many of them are scared to
death i've sent you testimony i can send
it again
five
five uh testimony type five written
testimonies that i gave out last year
too
they can't even say their name because
they've been threatened that if they do
anything that makes the gal or the
therapist or the judge angry
they know what's going to happen to them
they're going to lose custody so it's
coercive
it's threatening it's not like any
counseling you've ever heard of it
sounds more like
being in a north korean prison camp uh
in interrogation
it's that bad but you can make up your
own mind the testimony is there
women have said and it was two women who
said this to me they said to the court i
can't afford this with no insurance
coverage it costs anywhere from 150 to
350 an hour and it is common for them to
be ordered two hours a week
for months
so they've said
i can't afford this
and they were told
not on the record they were told your
parents can
there's one woman who would i'm sure
she'd love to testify and i'll make sure
she sends you hers
her testimony
her parents have paid out over
500 000 dollars
because they are so afraid of letting
the their grandchildren be
removed to their abusive parent other
parents home
um
i i'll send you testimony because you
know this could go this could go on
forever but this is a cancer in our
courts which is what one of the women
who is in the house of lords of england
called it
so i will take questions and i know
there are people who are wanting to
testify from their personal experience
and thank you deborah so much
madam welcome
representative gay
what percentage of services
that these families are receiving
don't have this cpt medical code
none of them have a cpt code it's all
reunification therapy is what they're
calling it right now which is the
official
it
it's the official terminology used
across
all these countries
reunification therapy and
parental alienation is what they accuse
the protective parent of because when
the children say they don't want to be
with the abusive parent the protective
parent who's tried to get help from the
authorities is accused of
follow up madam chair
follow up
so representative gay have you reached
out to the division of youth and family
services on how often that this is
happening
they are not i'm sorry
go ahead no they are not aware of it
because you see the families that dcyf
helps
don't have money
this is very targeted it's very obvious
who is ordered it's the families that
dcyf has never heard of this every
counselor that
like we have multiple counselors who are
representatives they've never heard of
this because everybody is scared to
death to talk about it
you will hear from one person
one person who testified a couple of
years ago and has already testified
today
she had to leave the state
and hide her child when her
to be ex
was given custody
he doesn't even live in new hampshire he
refused to come to the first two
uh hearings
but they knew there was money there so
they kept letting him
you know giving him another hearing to
go to
and she's the one who testified she was
never granted an evidentiary hearing
either
thank you any further questions for
seeing none um we will head on to
sarah
heiderbrecht
did you find her
please tell them they have to unmute she
just jumped to the yeah so give me one
second
i'm sarah you're allowed to speak now
okay um thank you
um
i submitted a written testimony
yesterday and in case i wasn't able to
join this part of the meeting
um
this bill uh to me is incredibly
important i would echo everything that
feeling in fear of
the retaliation that i could face for
testifying and
kind of calling out some of the
misinformation um
and orders um that are given by the
court
um
my situation is a little different right
now and that
we've been court ordered to co-parenting
therapy
which again
if you read my testimony
is not
a supported form of therapy
by the majority of mental health
practitioners in new hampshire
um
i
in the
process of trying to
um
find someone that conducts co-parenting
therapy
i
called 46 licensed mental health
practitioners in new hampshire
the majority of them do not um conduct
court-ordered therapy and furthermore
they don't do court or co-parenting
therapy
um
many of them had no idea what i was
talking about
um
and
to kind of complicate matters the few
that i did find who provided that
service
um it wasn't a billable code
um or they were very
ambiguous about well it may or may not
be covered by insurance
um
my child's pediatrician who tried to
help with the search to find someone to
facilitate this court order um
said quote
that said putting it all together right
now after the recent search effort
i think we're at an interesting place
for what is needed is clarification from
the court on what exactly the intent is
with the term co-parenting therapy
keeping in mind what is and is not
available as options within the
counseling world
complicating this whole matter for me is
that our case does involve domestic
violence and
doing therapy with my abuser is also not
a supported form of
it's not recommended by our domestic
violence agencies within the state
the gal knows this on our case yet he
continued to recommend it
stating that well perhaps i can do it
virtually instead
uh
that's that's not the point um
you know of domestic violence or or
feeling a power and control differential
um so
you know this bill is important
for one aspect of it but i feel like
continued education and domestic
violence
for all of our um support professionals
is incredibly
um needed
um
my my own primary care physician also
stated
uh when i asked them for assistance in
finding
a therapist said quote and unfortunately
i don't have
essentially any recommendations for a
co-parenting therapist i recently saw a
thread about a similar situation in
which the therapists were saying that
this is a challenge this is challenging
to navigate and the importance of
educating judges
in these cases
end quote um
so
again um
it kind of goes back to the judicial
system and
um
as part of the court order in our case
the judge also
um
in my opinion threatened me by
saying that
if the co-parenting therapist recommends
a psychological evaluation just for me
then i was responsible for it for paying
it out of pocket whether it was covered
by medical expense by medical insurance
or not
and um
i
took that as you know a slap across the
face because
if the judge was so worried about my
mental health wouldn't he
you know have removed my child from my
care
um
that's not the case
but it kind of goes back to what
representative gay was stating about
um
you know targeting certain parents
who may have
some ability to pay for these services
and
you know
what the court feels like they want the
outcome to be
um
really narrowing um
my ability to
um
put the facts on the table and just let
the
system see the facts instead of kind of
shuttling us through all of these
different interventions that that aren't
medically proven
so i'm sure i've over stated or over
talked my time but um
i appreciate you hearing my testimony i
hope you can read what i wrote
as well
and i hope you'll support this bill
thank you any questions
for ms
heiderberg
see none
um
we will next go to
miss heidebrecht do you have a written
testimony that you can
no she's gone
um
uh miss justina
yes am i unmuted
sorry sarah is
unmuted now
okay oh sorry um i did i emailed it
yesterday to the cfl uh email address
thank you oh you you probably have it
yep
miss justina you're unmuted now okay
thank you
um again my name is aaron jusina and i
direct the domestic violence advocacy
project at new hampshire legal
assistance and i'm here to testify in
opposition to house bill 556
as representative gate mentioned this
bill was proposed
last session a similar bill was proposed
last session
and that bill did die in chamber on june
16 2020.
so this bill seeks to stop reunification
therapy which i agree can be completely
triggering and further traumatic for
victims of domestic violence and their
children
but this bill unfortunately passed will
not accomplish that goal
therapists under this bill if it was
passed
could still provide reunion
therapy
while billing to a proper medical
medical code
they could just bill it as the generic
code for individual therapy
which would be considered a form of
mental health treatment and eligible for
insurance reimbursement
um uh members of this committee who uh
were here last year may remember that um
there was a working session on this bill
i believe it was in february um and it
was recommended that the bill be itled
and discussed that if reunification
therapy is the problem which i think
that is the issue raised by
representative gay
i also share concerns about
reunification therapy and its effects on
domestic violence victims and children
so if reunification therapy is in fact
the problem then that is what needs to
be addressed by a bill and this bill
does not do that it doesn't prevent it
it will not stop these situations that
representative gay uh mentioned in her
testimony
so i just urged the committee to
reconsider that as you considered it
back in february of last year
um consider that
as the issue and vote in expedient to
thank you do we have any questions for
seeing none we'll move on to the next
person on the list of people who would
like to testify
the next speaker is miss rhonda hodge
hi can you hear me okay
my name is rhonda hodge i own harmony
psychiatric services in salem new
hampshire
um i have a 20-year history i'm a
licensed mental health therapist but i
am also board certified in psychiatry um
so
under that i'm dr rhonda hodge
i've been working
with children
and families for
forever um i started my work actually
working with foster children who were in
trauma situations
i met betty um when i reached out to her
about a personal situation so i'm going
to speak to you kind of both clinically
and i think some of the answers some of
the questions that came about i might be
able to answer because i am doing
billing i as i own my own business i do
all of it um from start to finish and i
think it's important to mention that
there's no icd code for abandonment and
there's no ic decode for
child abuse
and when you're billing for a family
session um yes we could say maybe post
traumatic stress disorder
but you know it's really hard to say
that when the child is five or six years
old um
you're kind of creating things just to
be able to bill for something like this
and i actually agree with the last
speaker that the idea of unification
therapy is
disgusting um to say the least i
always trusted the system and i always
trusted the state of new hampshire in
court and i'm from new hampshire and i
went to started my education at flemish
state but some of the things that i'm
seeing have just been so horrifying to
me
um reunification therapy is attention is
um it's it's child abuse it's telling a
child and i would not say that like i
don't
speak that strongly
but it needs to be heard that it is
you're essentially
taking a child who has been abused
and you are telling them to never trust
i have never had a patient come in that
i would want that to be the outcome
i want them to know that yeah bud like
what you know is true so if you see
somebody down the line and you get that
same feeling that you got
with that person
i'm not going to convince you it's not
true just because a judge told me that
you have to be around that person i will
never
ever
ever take part in something like that
there will never be
a family that comes into my practice
that
i'm going to reunify them
with their physical or emotional abuser
i it goes against it's it's immoral and
it's unethical now of course there are
situations where reunification does make
sense right like there are going to be
situations where that looks healthy and
that could be okay
the situations the things that i've
heard of it's just such a broad spectrum
that it it doesn't make sense
um you have a female girl for example
who at seven eight years old was
physically or sexually abused and i used
female because
most of the uh
the abuse that you might see um
unfortunately happens to females but i
will not again um
like betty did i will not leave out
lgbtq or men this happens to everybody
but you take that child into
reunification
with her mom or dad
and you tell her that that was okay and
she should have to be around them again
then what happens when that kiddo is a
freshman in college what happens when
they are in us i'm gonna start crying
because it's just like
it's so hard to hear
that this is what's happening and also i
didn't actually hear betty mention
these reunification therapists aren't
necessarily me they're not clinical
most of them don't have licenses
i have a situation and i have to be
careful with because i have um a
personal situation too
of somebody who it's really a business
model they don't have a history of they
don't know about child development
they don't know about personality
disorders and most abusers have
personality disorders they don't have
the clinical skills they didn't go to
school for it
that's another reason the icd codes
won't work
is because they're not therapists
they're not licensed in the state of new
hampshire as an lmhc or
licsw and they
they didn't do the work they created a
business
based on something and they might have
like a supervising going along with it
i also spoke to a state rep because this
has been really heavy on my heart lately
as as i learned a little bit more about
it and
similar to what betty said he said to me
when i was telling him about a case he
said i bet you that mom has money
now the the facts of the case are that
the child the father has a 20-year
history of domestic violence
the father abandoned two children
abused the child that we were talking
about now
went missing for a while during the case
for over six months which in new
hampshire state of new hampshire is
abandonment
um he beat the mother of his first child
twice while she was pregnant to the
point of incarceration now abusers don't
get incarcerated so you have to know
it's pretty significant
and the judge ordered them it was the
mother's fault that she had a stalking
order
in the order it essentially said it was
her fault now that is in state that is
in the state of new hampshire now so
that's definitely something to look out
for that is a case that went through the
supreme court
um
so again as a provider i don't even know
what to tell my patients anymore when
they're in these situations
but
what the the person the state rep said
to me was
i promise you it's because that mom had
money
and
they know that she's going to put my
money into the judicial system
so i mean this is just like a super
layer cake but i i think that it's
really really important that
you understand that it's not moral it's
not clinical
there's no psychological basis behind it
and essentially it's making a kiddo
not believe themselves not feel like
they can protect themselves
um i actually i mean i would like i said
i was horrified i've
i have three master's degrees in
psychology a doctorate i've been doing
this forever i wouldn't even believe it
if you if i didn't hear from betty i
never would have believed that this was
actually happening it sounds like
something that came out of the 50s or
or 60s and
i don't know it's it's horrifying but i
definitely can answer any questions you
guys have about billing and what that
do we have any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony and we will move on to the
so that was the last on the list but i
have
paula
okay hi
it's very weird every time i unmute it
seems the program mutes me again
um i have submitted written testimony on
this bill
she's accurately describing what is
going on in new hampshire courts right
um
everybody knows about the case that was
in portsmouth and in foley's court
it was eventually transferred to lemire
and
after
and by the way there's there was no
subject matter jurisdiction for that
divorce i don't consider this woman to
be divorced
because
the
father who filed the petition for
divorce
was from washington d.c
he hasn't lived in new hampshire during
the entire
length of the case and the mother moved
out of state long enough to establish
child custody jurisdiction in
connecticut before the judge changed
custody
um
the bottom line is
i think the bill does need to be amended
to
specifically prohibit
reunification therapy
um i
it has to be called out and judges have
to know that this is a no-no
reunification therapy is unethical for
psychologists to engage in
so
the last speaker is right the ones that
do the
do engage in it
are licensed clinical social workers and
they don't have the extensive training
and she's also right that many many
abusers have
personality disorders and that includes
malignant narcissism and sociopathy
so you know the judges under the guise
of saying kids need two parents are
forcing these kids to be with terribly
terribly sick abusive people
um
also the national council of juvenile
and family court judges have stated
that
um
courts shouldn't even take testimony on
parental alienation
and
you've got more fully
um the information from them
but
they
uh you know it says basically i'm sorry
my dog is bothering me right now
um
you know testimony about parental
alienation
also needs to be
uh prohibited in new hampshire courts
and the courts aren't doing it so the
legislature has to do that
um
and
the claim of parental alienation is
almost always made
after
an allegation of abuse
domestic abuse or child abuse
um you know and you know disgustingly
uh judge foley actually wrote in an
order
well i i i'd considered giving you an
evidentiary hearing
but um
i decided not to because the gal says
there's no evidence of abuse
the gal lied
i know bill breen
she said that the uh dcyf report was
unfounded i've seen it
it was an incomplete assessment because
the man went back home to washington dc
the gal also lied about contacting other
witnesses and she had a stack of
affidavits on her desk from people that
had seen this man abuse the child
and and the child made a disclosure of
abuse to her which she was re required
to report to dcyf
and she did not do that
and then she wrote in the gal report
there's there's no uh evidence of abuse
so
it's disgusting she told me in her
office
we're going to do reunification because
it's what the judge wants this and by
the way there was never an evidentiary
hearing in this case
not any it was denied
um
and you know i'll tell you what the
reason is it was denied because this
woman wouldn't go
for
the alienation assessment with someone
that was known
to
diagnose parental alienation
practically all the time
um and you know if the judge couldn't
have his choice of witnesses he wasn't
going to let any in
um at some point there was
a psychological evaluation of this kid
and the psychologist
recommended no contact with the abusive
parent
the judge before that report was written
prohibited it from being introduced as
evidence
so of course he never had a hearing so
there was no chance to introduce it as
evidence
um
the new hampshire courts are a mess
but with resp
with respect to reunification therapy
i absolutely agree that this is child
abuse
countries like the uk have gone to a
different model there's been so much
research on child abuse
um in the last 20 years and our laws are
so far behind
the uk model is now called the
coercive control model
and i did attend i think it was in
december
a zoom seminar
uh by the dc superior court judges and
they are in the process of training all
their family court judges on the
i think that's going to better serve
people and i think that's the direction
and the other thing is is with my
written testimony i also submitted for
the record the national council of
juvenile and family court judges
judicial guide to child safety
and i submitted a scholarly article
written by a man on parental alienation
that basically
says that reunification therapy is
terrible
i happened to get a hold of him
yesterday in preparation for the
testimony
and he wished me luck he said you know
please make sure the legislature
questions
thank you are there any questions for um
i do see one representative grossman you
thank you madam chair
so i'm not sure who can answer this
question
this is
currently reunification therapy
um actually oh i i meant to mention this
and i forgot
cpt codes are for medical diagnoses
in the mental health field
it's the diagnostic and statistical
manual so it's actually a dsm code and
that is true
i believe for close to 20 years
proponents of parental alienation have
tried to get that code into the dsm
and they have failed every time they are
it is flat out rejected
and you know i think the last
dsm uh
revision
was i can't remember precisely when but
it was within the last five years they
have a follow-up
okay follow up
thank you so
how are
if people are being ordered to
reunification therapy
it's
and i've i've heard
about why it's not a good idea um
how are they billing it is it always out
of pocket or
are they able to get
providers
i mean i think that that's sort of the
issue in this as well but i'm just
curious right now if somebody's ordered
to reunification therapy
and
well
okay the statute authorizes judges to
order therapy taking into consideration
the party's insurance
they very well know that this
reunification therapy is not covered by
insurance
but
as they say when there's money to be had
they order it anyway
um and and
you know people have gone broke they
and by the way there's no statutory
authorization for judges to order
parental
um
you know assessments
in the context of discovery in my mind
that is the judge hand-picking his own
witnesses
and it is wrong it doesn't happen in any
other area of law even dcyf doesn't
accept the judge's choice of witnesses
which is mostly what i practiced when i
but people are just paying out of pocket
and and
you know in particular with judge foley
i'm perfectly aware that he has he
stated to people
um you won't like the order if you don't
do this
and you know i
i quoted i one supreme court case
where judge foley was the judge and the
wording at the very top of the opinion
was the parties agreed to an assessment
by dr ben garber
um you know blah blah blah and then they
went on to have the opinion well if
foley's the judge i can tell you
the mother agreed because she was afraid
the kid was going to be placed with the
abusive parent
um
it's it's not
it's not an agreement
it's it's coercion by the court
threatening to take your kids and hand
them to the abusive parent if you don't
do this
and and it's happened
thank you
thank you representative belanger do you
have a question
i do madam chair thank you um
my question is to um
miss wormy
um
how is dcyf billing for reunification
therapy
dcyf has a statutory mandate to reunify
families
they don't call it reunification therapy
what they have parents do is get therapy
to address the reasons that they abused
or neglected their kids
and then they wait for a recommendation
from the therapist to say yeah this
parent understands that what they did
was wrong
the the parent has to own up to his
behavior
and take steps
to address their behavior
the the current model in custody cases
is there's no requirement that an
abusive parent
own up to the behavior admit it
apologize
nothing like that
they're just forcing these kids to go
with people and by the way some of these
personality disorders
are completely intractable
you know
malignant narcissism and sociopathy
none of these
conditions
are amenable to therapy these are
basically lifelong conditions it's it's
not going to help these parents aren't
going to learn to not be abusive
follow-up manager
one follow-up yes
so because you didn't technically answer
the question
so but if i understand this correctly
you're saying dcyf doesn't bill for
reunification therapy
oh no it's it's not done in dcyf it
that's not what they call it at all
thank you next we have uh representative
petrigno has a question
uh thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question i just have a point
of clarification i thought i heard you
uh mentioned earlier that the cpt code
is for physical uh conditions but it
would be appropriate to have the dsm
code for uh reunification therapy if if
that's the case in your opinion
with this legislation
as written addressed the issue of
um
well there is no dsm code for parental
alienation because they refuse to put it
in the dsm
but no i think the bill does have to be
amended in my written testimony states
that i i think the legislature needs to
unambiguously prohibit
reunification therapy or even i i
actually think it would be a good idea
if the legislature
uh
prohibited testimony on parental
alienation the national council of
juvenile and family court judges
recommends that any references to
parental alienation be struck from the
record because it's junk science
yes thank you i understand that dsm
doesn't have a code for that as well so
i apologize but you get the gist of my
thank you will you take another question
please
yes
yes thank you and thank you for taking
my question
um
would you
consider
uh that this issue might be addressed by
uh restricting
the therapies that
can be ordered by the court to
no because so licensed clinical social
workers are licensed
and and they are permitted in new
hampshire to do therapy
um
i i think i mentioned that it's
unethical for psychologists to engage in
it so the vast majority of them
are
licensed clinical social workers
i do know that
one therapist that judge foley ordered
the woman
from portsmouth to go to
uh turned in her license
uh within days of of the judge's order
to go there and we recently discovered
that she's back in business calling it
you know family coaching or something
like that so she's just
gone right along and she's still doing
seeing none will go to the next person
uh
sorry madam chair i'm new to this i
apologize um the person that next to
speak would be
yes we can thank you again for uh
allowing my testimony today i i want to
also thank representative gay for um
being so perseverance in in this very
important issue
um
this again is alex giordano i spoke
earlier
i also testified on this very issue a
couple years ago i just want to make
some really quick points of
clarification if i may i'll be brief
um
first and foremost um i actually never
did or my child rather was never
fortunately um
uh
forced to suffer through so-called
reunification therapy
um in my case um
the father also wasn't interested in it
because
in my case he found out that he would
also have to pay for it and he he that
didn't sit well with him so
uh and then the other and combined with
that
the reunification therapist who's a
who's the most frequently appointed
therapist i think in the entire state of
new hampshire she's out of exeter
she withdrew she voluntarily withdrew
from the case um in part because
um i busted up to her and i said we're
going to bring this matter to an ethical
board and we're going to have you
investigated because this is what's
happening with her and what the courts
do and the judges actually
uh push this
is they have the reunification
therapists decide on their own without
even meeting the child by the way
whether or not their very expensive
reunification therapy is needed
and the national assoc association of
social workers uh executive director
came right out and said
what that's crazy that's you know that's
that's completely unethical
um so combined with that she voluntarily
withdrew the father
who sent me a text message saying we
both know uh therapy is bs
would not contact her
so
um
i did not we didn't we never engaged in
reunification therapy
um also another really quick
clarification before i want before i
make my statement on this bill
um
i legally redomiciled in another state
because there was never any hearings or
trial because there was always this
drive
by the judges not by the parents by the
judge
to force this reunification therapy
so i'm going to use that as a segue into
my testimony now on this bill
what this uh
committee really needs to grasp
is this is being
reunification therapy is is being
weaponized
they are using it in fact to weaponize
the abuser
against the abused child and in some
respects you know the the the women who
are abused
so if you're a protective parent
and you
assert
abuse and in my case also very important
to point out
all the abuse
evidence was
existed
long
and i stressed long before
the father filed for divorce in the
state of new hampshire
so there is absolutely no way to ever to
even remotely with a straight face try
to translate this into
so-called parental alienation
essentially what the courts are doing is
they are redefining protection of a
and they are using renification therapy
in a sense that is
fairly
tantamount to taking a
rape victim
and forcing them to go out on a dinner
date with their attacker
it is
no less demented
it's criminal in fact
um
as many other folks earlier spoke
there's a you know
i don't really so much get myself
involved in the lack of training
certainly there's a lack of training a
woman in exeter i think she uh
specializes in eating disorders with
with adults you know but it's it's
whoever will unethically take on these
jobs because they you know
making a lot of money you're making 200
bucks an hour and by the way it's per
head it's not per family so if you've
got three kids
that and you're going
that's 800 an hour i know moms that um
ended up we had one mom in our group
actually that ended up dying
um and her family has given me
permission they gave me her case anna
korlikova died
while fighting judge foley's order of
reunification therapy so she could get
her three kids back
she was getting a treatment for breast
cancer
and she stopped going to her treatments
to pay for the reunification therapy
that foley had ordered again with no
hearing of evidence for trial
um
and this is this is kind of how it works
the
arbitrary order
of reunification therapy almost comes
you could say before the judge even
meets you or even looks at your case
it's it's really a predetermination that
this is what's going to happen
um as i said earlier they declare they
don't want to hear any evidence they
just want to go into reunification
therapy
um i've never been in the sessions i've
heard about them i know they're
expensive um i cannot tell you how
grateful i am that we didn't have to
suffer through that
um i know attorney wermer had mentioned
that the
unethical
level of this is to such an extreme that
they are willing to use
therapists that are under investigation
for unethical uh contact or professional
misconduct uh one of those uh was
actually in the process of losing her
license
to the state of new hampshire
ultimately voluntarily agreed to
surrender it as part of a sort of a
secret settlement if you will with the
state
and in my case um even though we had
both parents
that were not interested in this
reunification therapy
um here's judge foley he's just not
going to take no for an answer you've
got the other therapist who has
withdrawn because she recognizes the
unethical ramifications for her
but you know
don't let a little thing like that get
in the way of judge foley he appoints
this this therapist who's under
investigation and threatens me
personally that if i don't
he says i recognize it as an option
but if you don't recognize that option
mrs giordano you're not going to like
the consequences one minute please
so
yes i appreciate that so
what you need to understand is this is
being used to it's usually essentially a
theft by extortion
if you don't jump through our hoops and
you pay the money
we're gonna take your kid away doesn't
matter evidence doesn't have anything to
do with it
your
you know earlier uh rhonda spoke she
broke my heart because i couldn't have
agreed with her testimony more
they are essentially this is just
another form of abuse you are trying to
tell a child
that their normal fear of somebody who
beat them up is not normal
and i want to touch really quickly i
know there's been a lot of discussion of
how effective this bill is
a couple years ago the state of new
hampshire made uh the news by
passing the first gay
conversion therapy bill
and if you look at that bill
that bill will guide you to how this
bill should be amended
what that bill did is it prohibited
therapists
from administering gay conversion
therapy
and if you just take out the words gay
conversion
and substitute it with reunification
therapy i think you're going to have
your answer on how to solve this problem
thank you so much for listening to my
testimony
last two speakers
uh you'll have five minutes each
mr head you're
unmuted
um i'm sorry can you hear me now
yes apologize my my computer switched
mike's on me um
uh for the record again my name is
richard head i'm the government affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch and
i just wanted to speak briefly to the
bill as written
which would prohibit
any counseling for anybody or for to
for counseling that does not have a cpt
medical code
and my concern
is really an unintended consequences and
tying the court's hands relative to
counseling um without sort of having
heard testimony as just sort of the
extent of that other than perhaps cpt
codes are not even the appropriate codes
that that were contemplated in the
purpose behind this bill we have
significant concerns that there may be
some significant unintended consequences
that
would limit the scope of of counseling
and
uh therapies
that are appropriate and are are
necessary
um
so we have we just have significant
concerns with with that
and also
well
with that i would be happy to take any
seeing none i'm just
i'll be with you in two oh we have a
question from representative altschiller
thank you i'll lower my hand in the
participants list now um mr had thank
you very much for being with us today um
you just met you just mentioned that um
this bill could limit the scope of
counseling services that are available
a little bit
i'd be happy to use in and
uh
and thank you for the question um what i
was meaning is that so for example and
i'm talking about the bill as written it
would
uh
would not allow referrals to counseling
that has no cpt medical code
and what what
is concerning is that the i don't know
that the committee really has a sense of
what is
or is not a cpt medical code and that
the court if this bill were to pass is
written
may find that some and
one that is universally acknowledged is
a inappropriate
uh counseling service under a particular
circumstance does not have a cpt code
that would be prohibited
um and i think we also heard you know
the cpt codes may not even be the
appropriate one when we're talking about
certain mental health counseling it may
be a different coding
um so that you know if this were to pass
you may unintentionally
counseling or therapy
that is not in dispute the way some of
the others are that were referenced in
in today's
testimony
thank you uh mr head is it your
experience in working with the courts
that um
they're that a code of
individual counseling
can be used
to throw an umbrella over a lot of
things
i think
so if i understand your question
actually i may not understand your
question i apologize um i can rephrase
there is there is a code that's called
individual counseling
i see in your experience with the courts
have you seen or would this bill allow
for that umbrella
to just shield all of these things that
we've been talking about today
you know i don't know the answer to that
i think there was earlier testimony that
it does happen uh and certainly i can
see it happening but i i do not know
specifically so i would i don't have
personal knowledge that would be able to
answer that question
thank you are there any further
thank you uh thank you for taking my
question i wanted to kind of follow up
on uh representative altschuler's
question
in in kind of going at a different um
angle
d
are you aware of any
uh
or
what
counselings might be requested by the
courts that
are not
uh
i don't i decide again on personal
knowledge i don't have sort of a list
certainly there are
times when when insurance will not
covered or or other parties simply don't
have insurance which is also not that
uncommon
um where you where you have uninsured
parties before before the court
so you know whether or not insurance is
paying for a particular
service as was noted earlier is a
consideration
but i don't have data on that
but that that is a that is as was noted
earlier one of the considerations for
the court to take into account when
so i think it's it's less of an issue of
whether or not it has a code for
insurance billing as opposed to whether
or not the party actually has insurance
and or whether or not
thank you we have uh one more person to
speak
great eric angarelli i'm the director
for the bureau for children's behavioral
health at the department of health and
human services um just a couple of
comments and i'm available for questions
if you have any to help clarify anything
most of the
commentary that i would have made has
already been discussed here today in
that the cpt codes are
sort of groupings of procedures um
that
lots of different things could fall
under uh to representative all
schiller's question yes a lot of things
could be grouped under individual
family or group counseling without an
identifier that gets to the actual model
that's being used and this is what i
think this is uh being discussed here
today is an actual model of therapy that
is in use so under the right
circumstances by the right provider this
could be billed to any one of those
individual group or family
therapies using those cpt codes so cpt
codes may not be
the way in which uh this becomes
addressed i also just want to clarify
um i don't represent dcyf but i've been
having a little bit of back and forth
listening to the testimony here today i
just want to clarify
the reunification work that is done with
regard to the child welfare system in
dcyf is different than what is being
discussed here today
again this is a model of therapy and the
work that dcyf does under their
reunification mandate is different and
does not necessarily employ something
like this
and i'm available for questions if
anybody has any
thank you ms angrily did you um submit
written test testimony
i did not submit anywhere if you could
please uh send that
and also seeing no further
hands up to testify
house bill
we'll be closing the hearing on
uh house bill 556.
we have 15 people on my sheet
that are supporting one opposing
i think that opposition is
probably going to go higher
and we had
so with that
we will close the hearing
and uh we will break for lunch
i'd ask you to be back a few minutes
before one o'clock
so that we can begin the hearing on
uh representative alessia i i did
neglect to mention that representative
stephen smith
has joined us and will join us after
lunch
he is joining us to replace
not that she can be replaced
representative
kim
rice if representative smith could just
um
comply with 91a and let us know where he
is and who's in the room with him that
would be great thank you
christine
representative smith can you do that for
us
i didn't quite hear what you said
can you tell us who you are where you
are and who you're with
yes i am representative steven smith i'm
in room 211 of the state house and
various staff wander through the office
and we are on
lunch break now
yes representative alessia
do i need to put a time as to when he
stepped in
uh you can ask him what time he stepped
in
representative smith can you hear me
i can
this is your time to log in
i believe it was
oh i think it was 1102.
thank you thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
so
um
oh i can't hear oh god
looks like the room is still muted
so the room will have to be unmuted if
you just go to the computer and hit the
other cody's doing that perfect
yes representative
i had a technical question not a um
question referencing any of the
bills is it okay to ask it
okay
so i haven't been clerk for two years
and doing it remotely is very different
so someone asked me earlier if i had the
blue sheets i don't have the blue sheets
i've made copies of everything myself
i dropped everything off on generally
fridays
or
karen and christine
so that they have the information
they do
tad amount to the blue sheet is the
information that i read
um
in the previous bills i will let me pull
this i'm familiar with it i remember and
i know how to do it but not being there
i
i'm not able to do that
that that was one thing and the second
thing is um
what was the second thing uh
in the past
um the assistant
used to get all of the
testimonies and all the information
and send them out or print them and give
them to us
so to have people send them to me and
make it my responsibility i'm not
getting paid to do that
so unless it's changed
and i wasn't aware if it's changed and
that's what i'm supposed to do
i will do that you can just forward
forward the email to children and family
law
that's the way it used to be forward
everything to children and family law
yes i misspoke earlier and gave your
name instead of children i really
appreciate that i always thought i
freaking killed i was like oh no not no
more
so i really appreciate that very very
much
and one more big favor if when they
start because it's hard to really
understand their names
they're supposed to state their name
where they're from
and if they have testimony so some of
the names i've spelled wrong because i
can't i don't want to keep saying i'm
sorry can you repeat that please
and it doesn't show on the bottom you
know on the screen all the time
for the next three bills we'll do better
and tomorrow i'll do much better
and i'm not complaining it's just for no
you're not
i don't think it has a complaint at all
thank you thank you so much
it's good for us to work together
because we need to be a team
and we've always done that yes we have
thank you okay i appreciate you
oh i appreciate you more than i could
ever play
yes
can you upgrade me again please oh of
course
so i hope everybody's back from the
lunch and you all had a good relaxing
lunch
uh representative alicea do you want to
certainly
i thought i saw her
well she's on the screen
are you having trouble
i'm good now thank you okay
uh representative
ballinger
representative chairwoman de simone and
vice chair desimone
i'm here in rooms 210 to 11 with
representatives
belanger and lewickie
thank you
hi everyone i'm here in exeter in my
snow
and i'm actually alone in my house yay
congratulations
i am here i am in my spare bedroom in
barrington alone
thank you
representative wiki
i'm here at the llb
thank you
representative litchfield
hi i'm here in my home um i am in the
room alone but i do have other people
thank you
representative long
representative petrino
um representative smith is here my three
children and my husband are home so they
could pop in at any minute
okay
wrong representative smith business
representative d denise smith that just
gave you the information
i'm sorry
that's okay that's okay um that's why i
didn't realize it was
usually there isn't another smith on the
call
that sorry
that's why i said for representative um
kim's
oh okay i'm sorry
it's okay it's fine
so now representative steven smith for
yes hi um i'm home with three of my
representative yocala
yes i'm
and representative alicea
my houseguest is stepped out i just have
okay
thank you representative i don't think i
have to read the disclosure again i read
it this morning
so with all due respect we will begin
this afternoon's
uh hearings um with house bill 577
relative to parenting and divorce cases
involving allegations of domestic
violence
and i believe we're going to hear from
representative gay you're unmuted
thank you
by the way it's a good thing to tell
people who aren't used to this that when
you tell them they're unmuted you have
to tell them to unmute too
one of them gave you fits because she
didn't know that
thank you very much for taking my
testimony
i'll read it very quickly when a
guardian at lightham is appointed to a
parenting case in which domestic
violence is suspected or alleged the
guardian ad litem shall promptly refer
the relevant party to a local crisis
center or assessment by a domestic
violence counselor as defined in rsa 173
excuse me excuse me representative gay
we're talking about um
house bill 577
oh i am so sorry oh that's okay dear
okay
we're back
i'm not used to doing four a day
i know and you have another one after
this so and that was it patience
i will be glad to tell the people that
that are sending testimony to send it to
the entire
cfl of
children and family law instead of just
bombarding you
thank you
okay
if domestic violence is identified as an
issue in any proceeding under this
chapter
either between the parties or between
one or both parties and a child or
children the case shall not be assigned
to the complex case docket or high
conflict docket the case
is criminal
and shall be assigned to the circuit
court district division or superior
court and of course that needs to be
modified because i'm not an attorney and
after getting told by an attorney it
needs to be changed
the wording needs to be changed so that
the case shall be assigned to the
circuit court district division our
superior court and be eligible for a
trial by jury
we have a strange situation in new
hampshire it feels strange to me
if you commit a crime against someone
who is not in your family
it's handled in superior court
with an with a jury
if you commit that same crime on a
family member
it goes to family court
the rules there are different and a lot
of times the results and the findings
are different
and usually
not so punitive
and not so protective of the victims
so
i realize this is a big
a big ask
and i'm also cons
expecting that two people who keep
refusing to acknowledge
our bills are any good
because they're defending the way things
are i understand that but the way things
are need to be changed and so this may
take multiple steps to make it happen
but i need your support that victims of
abuse domestic abuse need to be treated
in a same way that victims who are not
in that same family
i'm may have to uh guide me in saying
this but some of the people who speak
against
against my bills and of course i don't
have a chance to rebut them but of
course
of course they're going to defend the
way things are
and uh it's really a shocker when you
find out the people who are supposed to
be helping victims of domestic abuse
don't offer any way to strengthen the
laws i've asked them
face to face for suggestions on laws
that would strengthen their victims
uh in court and i was told that they
were too busy just reviewing bills
so with that in mind please ask me any
questions or give me
give me questions that have information
in them to help me
thank you
thank you representative gage do we have
lewicki
thank you madam chair thank you
representative
uh one of the things that i kind of
jumped out at me is it looked to me as
if this would could possibly be
weaponized by putting people into
criminal court
i could you perhaps clarify
um
saying the case is criminal because
or is it always criminal and if it is
criminal then why is it not tried
separately as a criminal
case i don't know
why
it's not tried separately
and of course nobody goes to court until
they've had a um
let's see what is it called
a
true bill true bill or no bill is that
term used here in new hampshire
it was in texas
you went before grand theory and they
decided whether you should uh even go
and be charged so i would assume that if
somebody is charging somebody or fi
against people they would go through the
whole process they wouldn't just be put
on trial they'd have to the grand jury
would have to assess whether they
thought there was enough evidence there
to make it worthwhile
but what's horrible is that in the cases
of
domestic child rape
you can't make it much worse than that
besides
trying to blow your children up which
has happened in new hampshire um
those cases are are heard in family
court
that's not the right place for them
and so this is my attempt to start the
ball rolling that we get uh the victims
of horrendous crimes
to uh have the same rights as a person
in superior court
after going through the correct steps
for a criminal court or superior court
thank you representative
thank you and representative um steven
smith you are here now can you state
whether you are here or not
and give representative ellis say your
whereabouts and with whom you are
i i'm here i am still in the office and
one staffer here
you
uh representative belanger you have a
question
yes thank you madam chair uh and thank
you representative gay for um
this bill um
while i
don't disagree um that perhaps this
should be a separate issue and maybe we
could amend that to happen
um
but
correct me if i'm wrong but this bill
states that if domestic violence which
suffice to say
off can often tend to happen
um with these families
that are impacted
this would take
the case completely away from family
court am i wrong to assume that
not all family court cases have horrible
things like that so it wouldn't get rid
of the need for family court it would
just take out
violent criminal acts
and put them where they should be
follow up representative belanger thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative gay for answering that
do you have you spoken with the
department
of um
youth and family services
to
get data on how many families are
no and
you know they
let's see how to say this
it seems like in our in our court system
we have systems that handle dcyf cases
and a lot of different things happen
in
i'm not sure how to call it private
divorce proceedings
that you know are not involved with uh
dcyf at all just like the cases the the
bills that we talked about before
going through
uh
the counseling that's not real
counseling
that
that's just totally not something that
are there any further questions for
seeing none we'll move on to the next
person on our list which is aaron
justina
miss justina you're unmuted oh okay
thank you
um so my name is erin jacina and i
direct the domestic violence advocacy
project at new hampshire legal
assistance
and i'm here today to testify in
opposition to house bill 577
um
i would like to address representative
gay's comments about defending the way
that things are
um
i am here today to testify
um against these bills
because they don't correct the problems
on behalf of domestic violence victims
they don't make things safer or better
for victims i'm certainly willing to
listen to potential amendments and
solutions but these bills do not do that
um
then i would like to say that uh there
was a similar bill which was proposed by
representative gay last session that was
house bill 1626
and this committee voted unanimously to
itl that bill 19-0
so there are really two things uh with
this particular bill and i'll address
them each separately the first one is i
think there is some confusion around the
complex case docket
uh when this bill was first drafted that
docket looked very different in our
state
it was really one statewide
case docket that has now been
regionalized
and it is up to each region to determine
how those cases are handled
but i believe there may be i think
richard had the court representative
hopefully he's still
on the zoom so i will let him speak
further to that point
next i would like to address the issue
of making this
these cases where there's a finding of
abuse
criminal and sending them over to
district division or to superior court
so if there is a finding of abuse made
in a parenting case that does not
necessarily make the case criminal
some of you may know that domestic abuse
can take many different forms it can be
emotional abuse it can be
psychological abuse it can be financial
abuse
physical
assault physical abuse is not i think
that's what many people think of when
they think of domestic violence that
there has to be bruises um there has to
be broken bones that is not the case
abuse can take on many many different
forms which unfortunately not all
situations rises to a criminal level
our law regarding domestic violence does
not encompass all of those things that i
just described to you so somebody may be
belittling their partner maybe
putting them down and making them feel
worthless
that is abuse but it may not rise to the
level of a criminal act under our law
and so we don't want these family court
cases which are not criminal
to be transferred over to a superior
court where judges aren't trained on
family dynamics or divorce and parenting
law
so in terms of cases being referred to
and that i think the issue is that um
and i've heard this in other bills is
that there may be a concern about some
of the judges that are hearing these
cases so let's get them out of family
court let's get them away from those
judges
to a different division or to a
different court
well in terms of district division that
wouldn't correct the problem if in fact
that was a problem
because the district so district
division and family division are all
part of circuit court so
there's the circuit court and then under
that is family division and district
division so the district court judges
are the same judges that are also
hearing family court cases
so that would not correct the problem if
that in fact was a problem
so for those reasons i'm asking the
committee to vote inexpedient to
legislate
and i will just add that i am happy to
at any point meet with any
representative who is sponsoring a bill
to provide any sort of feedback and
amendments which is exactly what i did
with these bills when they were brought
thank you miss messina any questions uh
can you out unmute yourself yes can you
hear me
yes ma'am
thank you um
so
miss justina could you
in your um description of
the differentiations between the courts
um i think it right at the front end of
that you mentioned
the um
that in
some cases of domestic violence
it doesn't rise to the level of a
criminal
um
finding or a criminal
a criminal case
so
could you could you just
could you just go over that one more
time before absolutely that's my that's
my question is a repeat of that piece of
your testimony
absolutely thank you for the question
i'm happy to do that yeah so
in the example i gave you have two um
parents they share a child
one parent is abusive to the other
parent
is putting that person down is saying i
wish you were
dead i hate you you're so fat
um you're ugly you're worthless you do
nothing for this house i contribute
everything financially you do nothing
what do you do for this family
that's horrible and that's abusive
and that is uncalled for and i think we
can all agree that that is not
appropriate behavior
but if that person in this case let's
just say
the mom
takes that to a police department the
police department is not going to charge
that person with a criminal act not
they're not going to say we're going to
arrest you we're going to charge you
we're going to bring this to the county
attorneys because how are they going to
charge that our law doesn't really
um account for that
if there was some criminal threatening
involved yes perhaps in that situation
um but the the reality is the police are
not going to charge that person
um
so it's not a criminal case and we don't
want those cases
to go
to superior court where they do handle
criminal cases we want these cases to be
heard
by judges who are trained and we want
them to be heard by judges who
understand rsa 458 and 461a
um
and honestly we don't want people
involved in family court cases to feel
like
they're involved in a criminal situation
we want to support families we don't
want to make them feel like they're
doing something wrong that's not to say
that there is not inappropriate and
abusive behavior going on in family
court and with
litigants involved in the family court
system there absolutely is and there are
thank you
yes uh thank you and thank you for
taking the question it seemed
i just uh wanted to clarify it seemed
that you
um
on one hand said that you were
advocating for this to not be moved um
to the circuit court um because those
judges weren't trained but then in the
next sentence you said that um if they
were moved to the circuit court it would
be the same judge that hears it so can
thank you for the question no it's too
different so superior court is separate
from circuit court
completely separate so within circuit
court you have family division and you
have the district division
so
the judges most times there's overlap
between the district court judges and
the family division judges they are
hearing
both kinds of cases within the circuit
court
does that make sense
i can
explain that a little better if
necessary
but i don't think they should be
referred to superior court because those
judges don't handle family law cases
but within the circuit court you might
have a district court judge who also
hears family court cases because they
thank you madam chair and thank you mr
cena for coming today and sharing your
testimony
i just have a question regarding the
definition of domestic violence
so
how does it get defined
um
and is emotional or psychological abuse
part of our definition
and then i do have a follow-up if other
states
do include emotional and psychological
abuse as part of
domestic violence cases if there is any
i'm not very familiar so
sure
so thank you for your question so under
173 b which is the law that we use
um to help a victim get a protective
order from domestic violence
the definition abuse means the
commission or attempted commission of
one or more of the acts described below
and those acts include assault or
reckless conduct criminal threatening
sexual assault interference with freedom
destruction of property unauthorized
entry and harassment
so it doesn't explicitly say
[Music]
psychological abuse mental abuse any of
those things certainly you know you
could make a case um
you know
there may be some criminal threatening
um in a situation that i you know the
one the example that i provided um
that there could have been some criminal
threatening
um within some of that psychological
abuse but for the most part it doesn't
encompass those things
um
so that's what we're left with at the
moment
um and i'm sorry what was the other
part of your question
whether
if there's any other kids law like our
other states
is there any movement towards that
emotional and psychological piece being
included in
cases
so i don't have the statistics in front
of me it's certainly um something that
we talk about kind of in the um
domestic violence advocacy arena is
whether or not and i think some states
have probably moved to do this to
include psychological abuse within the
definition of abuse
because we that's frustrating because we
know that that is abusive and coercive
controlling behavior
but our laws don't always
[Music]
include those things
so
i can't answer your question directly as
to which states i think there are some i
could certainly get that information for
you
i just don't have it at the tip of my
any further questions
from mr cena
thank you mr cena thank you
uh we'll now go to our next
hi again um i hope you guys had a nice
lunch
um so i just wanted to speak to a couple
things that were brought up um and i
didn't i didn't hear her name um but
from the coalition against domestic
violence i mean she brings up a lot of
really great points um
but they're one of the first comments um
there's not going to be any data and
unless you're working for the coalition
or you're working or you have a passion
for really helping this particular
population
there isn't going to be any data because
it's ignored right so if um
for example i have one case right now
that's one of my patients that i'm
working with and i'm honestly
the coalition doesn't have enough people
or enough time to be able to help as
many people so i try to help as much as
possible as well
who a judge just told her she's in a
domestic violence situation she's been
unable to get a restraining order we've
shown pictures of
her having
the
the uh the ex having
guns saying he's going to he's going to
kill them um
there's
pictures of abuse this man has never
been arrested i mean i think it's really
important that we point to the fact of
how bad it really is and how nothing is
really actually being done even if this
particular person was to have a
restraining oh in family court the point
i was trying to make is that the judge
actually called her a spoiled brat
um and they're allowed to be abused so
that's i mean that's one point but the
other point is that even if she had a
restraining order or even on that family
parenting order there is a restraining
order it is civil and it doesn't mean
anything
um so even if she was to have a
restraining order speaking about another
patient whose tires were slashed and she
called the police and the police said
well we can't prove it's him so
there's nothing they can do
so these people aren't being arrested um
there's criminal threatening happening
there's physical abuse
it's not being treated as criminal they
go into the family court and it's almost
as if in when they're in the family
court and they're talking about custody
and divorce and all of these different
things
it's well this happens in families right
this is what it looks like if i have the
most horrifying pictures from some of my
patients and i help them like i said i
help them kind of put it together so
that when they go to a an attorney or
they go to the police they're able to
speak because these
men and women but mostly women are
speaking will their voices completely
shaking
they're having to go to court they're
having to face their abuser and
one that's not fair
they're expected they're going to look
weak they're going to look like it's
their fault
their abuser the state of new hampshire
is telling them that
they didn't do anything wrong right when
you do something wrong you get arrested
or you're held accountable for it
um i think that's the biggest part that
betty's trying to make from this is that
there's no accountability in family
court um and like i said there's not
gonna be any data because there just
isn't
there isn't any there just isn't any
accountability i think one of the very
first comments too um is i don't know
who it was that said it and i'm
i just want to bring up the bias um i'm
definitely not trying here to hurt
anybody's feelings but
the very first question that said is
can't this be used as a weapon so if we
bring this over to family court um over
to criminal court couldn't this be used
as a weapon
that is the reason that i am speaking
right now
women
specifically mostly they don't lie do
you know how hard it is
that's the first thought is that women
are lying
they're using this as a weapon
and
they are at they have to be able to
prove it more than their
abuser has to prove they didn't do it
that's just society that's what we go to
is that parental alienation it's it's in
us it's in our society it's how we're
raised i promise you
that going to family court or going to
court and saying that you were raped
saying that you were physically abused
these people are so vulnerable it is so
scary even if it even if it was barely
anything just walking into court and
nothing happened to you
you probably get nervous
people aren't going to go to those
lengths unless they are
i mean a very extreme sociopath
so i think that that assumption the very
first assumption is that people are
lying and they're they're weaponizing it
against in within their divorce case i
just really need like this this group to
hear that that's not true
i want the assumption to be that people
are telling the truth
not that they're lying we can look to
find out right but the assumption would
be that they're telling the truth
and that is just something that societal
is inbred in us is that they that it's
used as a weapon is that they're lying
um and then like i said that the
restraining orders and the stalking
orders like nothing happens anyways so
there isn't going to be any data there
isn't it's not considered criminal
families fight right people get there
people get get hurt kids get hurt when
they're in toxic relationships and
that's the frame of mind
i've never actually had
one of my the people that i've been
working with
in some of the most horrific stories
including sexual abuse
from
a mother and boyfriend nobody's ever
been arrested
so it's never been treated as a criminal
case and
those people the abusers typically get
custody
so that's all
i also sent some clarification on
billing and icd codes during the break
because i knew that that was confusing
about the last one at the end
thank you do you have written testimony
um i do not but i'm happy to happy to do
it
please send that to the children and
family law site
absolutely
seeing none i will let you know that ms
hodge is the last person on my written
list to testify
although i do see a couple of hands up
and i believe it's for
people who
want to testify and the next person with
could you please state your name where
you're from
who you're representing and whether
you're in support or not in support
i'm in support of the bill with an
amendment um
and i i do believe that the language
needs to come out um
and where are you from and who are you
representing
i'm representing myself
and i respectfully decline to tell you
where i'm from because i am also afraid
of one of the losers that we're talking
about okay
i don't live in new hampshire anymore
but i practiced my entire legal career
in new hampshire
okay
um
with respect
you know i had a kid
that was uh
in a very abusive relationship in her
twenties
and at the time my husband and i were
estranged from her
but we knew about the abuse because in
uh two years
uh we watched the insurance pay out a
hundred thousand dollars in the er bills
uh you know i
at this point it was many years ago and
um i i forget precisely how many trips
that represented
um
i do believe that these cases need to be
heard
in a different
court and
my thought is that superior court judges
are the best trained
with respect to the rules of evidence
and that's because the criminal defense
bar uh files a lot of emotions you know
um
there's there are many many evidentiary
motions in criminal cases
um
and i i don't think the family court
judges are well trained on the rules of
evidence
and i'll just give you know aside
again i'm supplementing my written
testimony that you people should have
had from before
um
we've you know we've talked about there
actually is a new hampshire case law
that says
a parent that alienates a kid should not
benefit from the behavior
and therefore it was okay to give
custody to the other parent
um the facts of the case were pretty
clear
that
what
the one parent that lost custody did was
kind of turn her kids against the father
after the divorce was filed
let me tell you what there is not a case
on there isn't a case on parental
alienation
whether it meets the evidentiary
standards for admissibility i think it
would be
an easy case to say that a superior
court judge if somebody said let's have
a hearing
on
whether or not
uh parental alienation is even
admissible
which by the way is probably by the time
you pull in experts a fifty thousand
dollar hearing not anybody can afford
one of those
um
you know it involves expert witnesses
and probably a lot of them would be
coming from outside the state
um
but a superior court judge would get
that
and and would would go ahead and
schedule the hearing and have the
hearing and listen to both sides of the
argument
um
you know but but that said something
like parental alienation is um
highly
um
you know it's been it's been struck down
and declared inadmissible
because it's junk science
um
and and i have to tell you
you know when a family court judge and i
i'm just going to read from my testimony
for a minute um
judge foley stated
in his order dated january 10 2019 in a
case
i've considered the idea of setting an
evidentiary hearing on the issue of
whether mr
whatever abused the child the gal said
there was no objective evidence of abuse
if i found abuse by mr
it would do little to alter my
obligation to reunite him with the child
after he addressed his abusive behaviors
in some way in an appropriate
therapeutic setting
rsa 169 c19 and rsa 169 c23
he's absolutely wrong on the law
this you know a custody case is not a
and frankly he might as well have
written i considered the idea of
affording you due process but i decided
against it i always mandate kids spend
time with their abusive parents anyway
his his entire judicial philosophy and
mind you he was the only complex case
docket judge for
it can it conflicts directly
with
the factors of he has to identify abuse
and how it's impacted the child
on the relationship between the child
and the abusing parent in making a
custody decision
that's rsa 461 a6
uh roman numeral 1j
excuse me miss burma are we still
talking about house bill 577
yes
thank you
so
you know i
i don't think family court judges are
well trained i i think
sending a case to a superior court
would be a much better thing to do in
cases of abuse i i think it would be a
good idea to amend the bill and also
state that these people are entitled to
a jury trial on the issue of abuse
perhaps not the other issues identified
in the divorce
but
in particular now
with the current
um
system of the judges picking the gals
and the judges
picking
these
alienation evaluators
they're picking their own witnesses
and i'd i don't think a superior court
judge would do that or he would
certainly be much less likely to
thank you very much for your testimony
it's been helpful
are there any questions
representative belanger will you take
questions ms warma oh yes thank you
i have two yes ma'am thank you um
i will ask one at a time and then follow
up yes ma'am
um
when you referred to judges picking
gil's are you familiar with the
situation that you can petition for your
own gil you do not have to have it
appointed by the court
i am not aware of that
and i have never seen it happen
although the last case i involve i was
involved with was the case in portsmouth
and foley's and lemire's court
and i actually had not
done a custody case for years before
that
but
this case was an education for me
re-education
follow-up madam chair
and just for clarification i have a gal
in my guardianship case that i asked to
be appointed the judge
uh did not appoint him um
appoint the gal himself um when you
refer to judges aren't trained in family
court can you provide the data that you
have on that
well when they're making
you know they're they're appointing
these evaluators that they aren't
statutorily
and and
you know the direct answer is no i don't
have data because i did a right to know
with the judicial system and they told
me
that um
i asked for a table of contents for
judicial training for family law court
judges and they declined to give it to
me
now i will say that i have not
reissued that request for information
since the new hampshire supreme court
case
about the right to know law last year i
think it was
but but they refused to give me the name
of the trainers any out any contract
trainers they refuse to give me a table
of contents of how they're trained they
refuse to give me any any information on
how judges are trained
no more followers
thank you any further questions from
seeing none thank you miss worma
and we have one more hand up uh
richard head
i believe you want to testify and if so
please state your name where you're from
whether you support or do not support
sorry about that i thought i clicked on
it
mr head let's try that again let's try
that how's that
uh better now
yes thank you perfect sorry about that
um for the record my name is richard
head i'm the government affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch with
the chair's permission maybe five
minutes
and i'm primarily testifying for
information um the bill
had you know in terms of of background
um as i think you heard before from ms
justina
the circuit court is made up of three
divisions the family division district
division and probate division and this
occurred in 2011 when district courts
were eliminated and uh and consolidated
into the circuit division or a circuit
court system
and as you heard before there were in
previously there was a system of marital
masters that with the creation of the
circuit court system
have been have been fading so as marital
masters retire they are not being
replaced with marital masters but they
are being replaced with circuit court
judges
and as
and i believe there are only two masters
still in the system
and as those two retire they will not be
replaced with other masters but again
with circuit court judges circuit court
judges are
incredibly busy they're incredibly
knowledgeable of rules of evidence in
rules of court
and they do
you know there are some that focus more
obviously on family
um and some do it uh i don't know if any
of them i don't know how much we're
doing exclusively but there is with the
circuit court system
um cross training and and in district
division and
family division types of cases
so you have these
very knowledgeable
judges in
evident rules of evidence rules of
procedure
who are hearing cases both in the
district division and in the family
division
when domestic and just rough numbers um
family court family division
in 2020 had about 15 000 cases
of those about 3 600 had some 36 3 700
of those had some allegations of
domestic violence um involving the
involved in the case
and these are these are not criminal
cases um so unlike
as the sponsor said and i get
what she was saying
when representative gay was saying that
in superior court
the you know when it's not a family
member involved they're in superior
court and they're being
charged criminally
family court is not a criminal court it
is a family court and it's governed by
the rules and the statutes that govern
family uh
parenting divorce whatever the issues
may be
that would not change if it's filed in
superior court
the same rules apply the same statutes
apply the same
procedures would apply
um so simply moving it to superior court
is the only the only impact is that
you're moving it to judges who do not
hear these types of cases every day
do not have the depth of knowledge of
family practice and procedure
and it's a very complicated area of law
so you you would not have that level of
experience
if you moved these into the superior
court system and that's a significant
concern
the other aspect of
the bill itself
which would be you know basically
it's it really is fairly simple it
simply says the case shall not be
assigned to the complex case docket or
high conflict
docket that type of case assignment is
you know essentially a court function of
how do you allocate the resources and
the very limited resources
of the of the judicial branch in terms
of hearing what are in fact
you know they tend to be more
complicated cases they tend to have more
issues they tend to
involve a great deal more time and in
the just sort of efficient management as
efficient as we can be the efficient
management of cases
um those are are allocated within you
know the family division uh the regular
the sort of regular track and then the
complex track in order to sort of keep
the more complex cases from
slowing down all of the other cases
uh in in sort of an essential management
tool that the circuit court has
developed
and also as you heard um
from from ms justina our attorney
justina this is not
um current it's no longer a single
statewide um but it is regionalized and
mostly within you know the various
circuit courts
and there's essentially it's assigned to
a more
seasoned and experienced judge
uh in these areas so the you know those
essential functions of the management of
the court docket are
uh
are why we have an administrative judge
and why judge king is is
you know works very hard in terms of
managing how these dockets work
and then the the bill also says the case
is criminal and shall be assigned to the
circuit um court district division or
superior court and in fact these are
marital cases they're not criminal cases
um so criminal cases are brought by
prosecutors and i and i understand and i
get the issue of whether or not
prosecutors are filing these
uh or police are charging but these are
family
and and marital matters
they are not criminal matters held to a
criminal standard of proof
where somebody is going to go to prison
or have a criminal penalty at the end of
the day
these are these are marital cases that
are governed by the by the statutes and
the rules um of the court the statutes
that you all have laid out relative to
parenting divorce
um
and
uh and reunification so
i don't think this would accomplish what
the sponsor wants um and in fact would
be substantially detrimental to those
cases because
um they would be moved into
if it stays within the district division
essentially
the same judges
um and two it's moved into the superior
court you are talking about a a system
that does not have
you know the same number of judges the
same experience in in marital matters
and would ultimately
create significant management problems
both in the docket but also in
in terms of
the the outcome of these cases
so i do think while it may be well
intended uh and i appreciate that i
think the the
the bill itself creates
significant issues and concerns relative
to
you're really implementing a docketing
system for the for the court which
which it's doing to
to manage a very heavy caseload
of of these types of cases
um
the
again i guess i'll i'll rest with that
and i'll be happy to answer any
questions thank you
thank you mr head any questions i see
one hand raised representative alt
shower
thank you very much madam chair
um thank you mr head for being here
um for the day almost and
you all get the longer dave
yeah um and answering all of our
questions
i want to
i want to go back and ask i have two
questions for you one is could you
clarify
you just mentioned
identified
in a court proceeding then
instead of the
what this bill seeks to do instead of
the referring it to a different docket
it would require this bill would
actually require that it be referred to
county prosecutor county attorneys for
prosecution
to draw up charges is that what you're
saying
no i thank you for the question so i
appreciate that because i obviously was
not clear
what what i'm saying is that
um
not every domestic violence case goes
into
the
complex case docket that is an element
that is considered
in the complex case docket assignments
but not they don't all go there
what i'm suggesting is that
by virtue of of what this case is which
is a family case
it is not a criminal case as it is
before that family court judge
and that would not change if it is moved
into the superior court it is still a
family
court case it is still a family case and
it is always going to be governed by
um
by the by the family court
or the family law statutes and rules
what what i am saying is that
these are not cases that are being filed
by prosecutors
or law enforcement these are cases being
filed by private individuals involved in
in family matters so if a prosecutor
files the case
as a criminal case which is what not
what we're talking about here
if a prosecutor files then depending on
on the nature of that charge whether it
be a misdemeanor or a felony
it would be filed in either the district
division or the superior court and
handled as a criminal case
and sometimes you can have a criminal
case involving a party involved in a in
a marital case
so the
the the claims are different the types
of cases are different
the burden of proof is different and the
outcome
is different these cases that we're
talking about today are our family court
in without regard to who what judge is
deciding it the outcomes are family
related outcomes they do not result in
prison time they do not result in
criminal penalties
those are reserved for
cases that are filed by prosecutors as
criminal cases
and that's not what we're talking about
here
may i follow up madam chair
yes follow-up so mr head when there are
criminal cases
that
involve parties who are also
subsequently concurrently
in with a family court case
does a criminal court case or finding
inform the family court
case it could yes
it could okay and one last question
madam chair if i might
sure um in a family court case if there
is no
if a parties are involved in a just
strictly a family court case
and there are allegations of domestic
violence that don't rise to the level of
what our statutes have
at what our laws have as a criminal
prosecution
within the family court structure
is
the um
[Music]
the um what is the word i'm looking for
do we not have to just rise to the
preponderance of the evidence versus
clear and convincing
yep the beyond reasonable doubt and and
clear and convincing are all the higher
standards that a criminal court and
sometimes
that's why you may not see a criminal
case filed
because the prosecutor may have reviewed
the evidence and for whatever reason
decided that at that very high level of
proof um
whether it be the the victim or
the way the the victim didn't want to
pursue a criminal case even though it it
may be an element in the family case
um
there are a whole host of reasons why
but there is a different burden of proof
and a much higher burden of proof
on a prosecutor in a criminal case than
what you see
before in a in a family law case
thank you for the clarification thank
you
thank you uh representative yo kelly you
have a question
yes thank you uh thank you for taking
the question um a previous speaker
talked about um the training for
family court
judges and would you be able to
send the committee some
uh
information on what what trainings the
uh family courts have
um i'll see i'll i'm happy to ask judge
king his uh and i i'll i'll follow up
with him uh he had as you may have seen
in the paper death in the family
um so he's not here today but um i will
i'll follow up with him and let you know
i don't know i i just don't know what's
available so i'm not trying to avoid the
question i just don't know what he has
that would be available for me to give
i have one more question representative
long
thank you madam chair uh yeah thank you
mr head i could
could you give me a little bit of a
experience with respect to
pro se
litigants i you know a lot of these
bills i'm looking at this one this one
also is
you know for the low to moderate income
person who cannot afford attorneys
how how would this affect their
um
you know and this is on both sides the
one accused and the one accusing um if
neither one of them have the uh
wherewithal to pay for some of this
stuff how does this affect
how does this affect their case
i
i guess i'm not sure it would in the
sense as i said before
you no matter who the judge is and what
the building is you're walking into
whether it be a superior court building
or a circuit court building
um
the
the rules are the same you have fewer
superior court judges so you you may
have a greater backup
in in circuit court to be more direct
the vast vast majority of people are
unrepresented
um you have relatively
in terms of the total you you certainly
have judge or lawyers in in the circuit
court um but there is a huge percentage
of of parties in circuit court who are
unrepresented
um
and
you know i think
by
moving it into superior court is just
physically different it feels different
i think it may be more intimidating
um
but it's also hard for me to just to
really know that because i've been
practicing for 30 years so it's it's
more familiar to me but i think
that atmosphere is certainly different
than the circuit court and i think the
circuit court is
better has greater experience
uh
in dealing with
pro se parties i think you just see a
greater percentage of pro se parties in
circuit court
where the the clerks are more familiar
with that environment the judges are
more familiar
and as i said before this subject matter
is
is a circuit court subject matter not a
spirit court subject matter so i think
you would you would have greater
difficulty
with pro se parties in a superior court
setting
but i i that's that's my personal view i
don't have any
any evidence of that okay so a quick
follow for me uh madam chair
yes a quick one the um
yeah so i've heard from constituents who
have said that in circuit court the
clerks do help out quite a bit
um so
i'm hearing that in superior court that
luxury may be less of
less
have
to happen
i think not by any fault of anybody but
i think the experience level is much
different in spirit court than circuit
court given sort of the the volume of
cases and
the numbers that are represented by
lawyers and those that are not and i
think it's just a more
familiar experience for the for the
clerks and staff in the circuit courts
um than you see in superior court and
and again
it it comes in part down to
just sheer volume
very good thank you
thank you thank you for the question
thank you mr head and thank you for all
your great questions everyone
um with that i'm going to close the
hearing on house bill 577
we have 11 people supporting two
opposing that's what's on my sheet the
numbers could be different you can check
the blue sheet in the office later if
you'd so choose we had five people
testifying
um thank you and with that we will open
the hearing oh yeah we're about 35
minutes behind schedule just to let you
know
um but i want everybody heard
uh and i want everyone who wants to
testify to testify
so with that we'll open
the hearing on house bill 548 with
representative gay
thank you
and i really appreciate you giving
people time to to testify it's
nerve-racking as we all know
um okay this is on 548 and the gist of
it is when a guardian ad litem is
appointed to a parenting case in which
domestic violence is suspected or
alleged the guardian at lydem shall
promptly refer the relevant party to a
local crisis center or assessment by a
domestic violence counselor as defined
in rsa 173 c1 roman numeral 3
and in appropriate cases comply with
mandatory reporting requirements for
child abuse under rsa 169 c 29
the guardian item shall also determine
whether law enforcement completed a
lethality assessment protocol regarding
any party to the proceeding
when i've talked about this before
i was told that uh it wasn't fair to
to uh refer a party a demand a victim of
domestic violence it wasn't a good idea
to refer them to a domestic um
uh crisis center
and i'm thinking if they choose not to
go
that's their choice
this is not forcing them to go but this
is where they're going to find people
who know what the situation is who can
advise them
that's why they're there
and uh so i'm i'm prepared for the same
person to criticize that again
and then the other somebody said they
didn't like this idea about telling the
guardian at lightham that they should be
checking on the if there is any
lethality assessments police are
supposed to write up a lethality
assessment when they go to uh
domestic
disturbance but
unfortunately that's not done very much
perhaps if they started getting asked
about it they would and certainly those
who have done it the information is
helpful
because
the people um
it's
one of the problems is
that
under this this mindset that has been
imposed on courts that we're trying to
overturn about alienating parents being
alienating and
is that
the person who says there's violence or
abuse going on
is automatically suspect for making it
up
and so i was hoping
but i that didn't work i was hoping that
if they went to the crisis center got uh
interviewed
assessed by a specialist domestic
violence specialist they would have
somebody a report to to cite
but that's not the way our crisis
centers are set up
and i do appreciate representative
altschiller trying to explain to me how
the system
how the system works because we know the
crisis centers do a huge amount of good
for
victims of abuse but they cannot testify
so
uh i figured well the police are
supposed to be writing these lethality
assessments so at least the guardian at
lightning could see if there are any
because that would be useful
um
what's really
disappointing to me is to find out that
in new hampshire at least and i
understand that in many
it's standard practice around the
country
here you have guardian at lightums gals
gals
appointed
for and
uh representative belanger was lucky if
i understood him to say he did get to
choose his guardian at lightham
you can shake your head yes or no
yes so that was great but all the people
that i've met and have suffered terribly
in court they didn't have a choice and
the gal said oh
you you've you've alleged there's
domestic violence or domestic abuse so
your children have to be
uh
they have to go and have these sessions
with the parent that they don't want to
be with
and yet we find out that here the gals
have a tremendous responsibility and a
lot of credibility
with the judges who appoint them
only they're not required to have any
kind of psychological education
and they darn sure don't have any legal
training either they might have a
smattering a couple of courses here and
there but they are not psychologists and
they are not attorneys and yet the child
their the child's future depends upon
these people
so um some people would just really
uh really like to do away with gals so
maybe we ought to just make sure they
have a lot more training than what they
have now
the child one of the things that's
really upsetting to find out
children are automatically assumed to be
unbelievable they are not permitted to
speak
so in a famous case in california the
daughter of a famous wealthy attorney
was forced to live with him they
followed all those awful rules we've
been talking about so they took her away
from her protective parent and gave her
to him
despite all the allegations of abuse by
both the daughter and the mother
the girl's gal refused to report the
abuse
after two years the girl was now she was
11 when she was awarded to him after two
years the girl was able to run away
when she was picked up she was put in
the juvenile section uh
what do you call the juvenile legal
a program for the state
and about the abuse
and she was placed back with her mother
and there is a fabulous article that she
wrote
at the age of 16
that is you would never guess it was a
teenager who wrote it it was excellent
and if i can find the the link i will
include that in my testimony
just yesterday i wish i could show you
this but
you know i'm not a panelist
this is just published on the 2nd of
march
31 missouri judges recused themselves
from lawsuit alleging family court
guardian and psychologist orchestrated
money making scheme gee where did we
hear about that before
so it's just sad that our system allows
very untrained people to be
such
uh
to be such legally
representing children who aren't ever
allowed to testify or to be interviewed
and have their testimony ordered the
only the only persons who can speak on
behalf of the child are the ones who are
appointed by the judge
so that just is totally needs to change
so
all i did in my bill all i could see
that i could do was ask them to
recommend that the victims
the alleged victims
they have to say alleged uh
recommend that they go to place that is
set up to help them
and the other is to
call the police find out wasn't a was a
lethality assessment ever made
so with that i will take any questions
if you want
our advice
thank you representative are there any
representative all chiller you have a
question
you need to mute i'm you you need to
unmute dear
so sorry
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative gay um
i'm
wondering if
you had
sought out the advice of the lethality
assessment protocol steering committee
and what their opinion was
well i'd like to but i'm unaware of them
thank you any further questions
um the next person on the list that i
see
is a david goldstein that wants to
[Music]
well you have a question i apologize
i have a question from representative
gay from representative
belanger
uh thank you representative gay and
representative gay when you refer to
guardian all items or gil's
not
they are mandated reported reporters
however but
um
are you aware of any that are
attorneys as i believe there are quite a
oh i'm sorry
i am not aware
i just know about the cases
that
have been brought to my attention where
they weren't there's nothing that says
they can't be
and they are paid by the parents
and one of the problems is
in the cases that i've been made aware
of that bad things are happening
they're representing the parent who's
paying for them
much more so than they are the
children's best interests that doesn't
mean that all of them are doing that
it's just that that's what i'm trying to
thank you
um
the next person we have on our list is a
david goldstein
are you here if you're here um
can you please raise your hand i see one
person signed in as a wise man
and if that's you mr goldstein please
um it's chief goldstein
uh madame chair and i don't know that
well thank you for clarifying that he
did not sign in as chief
otherwise i would have
thank you i appreciate it
i'm sorry he just got called i got a
text message he has just been called
away
um
so
okay well we'll we'll take the next
person on the list then uh and maybe
he'll be back um
by that time and the next person on the
thank you madam chair and thank you
members of the committee i just
before i get into my testimony i just
want to say thank you for taking the
time to hear my testimony today you've
heard a lot from me today
so thank you for your time and for all
you are doing i'm sure it's a marathon
day for you all
again my name is aaron jacina and i
direct the domestic violence advocacy
project at new hampshire legal
assistance
i'm here today to testify in opposition
to house bill 548
as i mentioned previously
this
bill is also similar to a bill that was
proposed by representative gay last
session
that was house bill 1626
and this committee voted unanimously to
itl that bill 19-0
respectfully this bill is well intended
and meant to protect victims of domestic
violence but it does have potential to
cause even greater harm to victims
this bill would require a gal to refer a
party that they suspect is a victim
of domestic violence to a local crisis
center
this can create three issues and i'm
going to walk you through those three
issues
the first one is that without proper
training or screening techniques the gal
may misidentify the victim in the case
and instead refer the abuser to the
crisis center
so if the crisis center then starts
providing services to that person the
actual abuser
in some cases it may preclude the crisis
center from providing services to the
it's possible in that situation that a
victim could then the victim in that
situation could be referred to another
crisis center but it may not be the
crisis center that is anywhere close to
them and it would be more difficult for
the victim to access those services
which we certainly don't want to make
things more difficult for victims
issue number two
is that choosing to seek services from a
crisis center is empowering one should
not be required to seek them well this
bill does not require a victim to accept
services from the crisis center the
victim may feel obligated to do so
because a gal a court appointed official
is asking it of them and maybe may be
concerned that non-compliance will look
uncooperative in the gal's eyes
and lastly so the third issue
is that this bill has potential to
inadvertently waive the privilege under
173 c
which is the
statute that protects the privilege
between
the victim who is accessing crisis
center services and the crisis center
counselor or advocate
so if the party starts receiving
services from a crisis center and
discusses those services with the gal
who then uses that information
to make a report to the court
that maybe it considered a waiver of the
privilege and then all communication
that victim has had with the crisis
center
may be considered fair game
and we certainly do not want to risk
that safe space becoming another avenue
to further the abuse of that victim
so for all of these reasons i
respectfully ask this committee to vote
an expedient to legislate on house bill
548 thank you so much
seeing none thank you very much for your
uh testimony
take a deep breath
you've been awesome today
and we will go on to the next person
we don't have anybody else on the list
however i do see two hands raised
and i will give her two minutes
okay
i'm sorry my computer keeps remuting me
after i unmute i don't have a lot to say
about this um i was actually pretty
impressed with the
testimony of ms justina
i think the bill could be amended
easily
to require
the judge to give a victim of domestic
violence
um information about a crisis center
um
but again
you know you still have the worry that
if the person doesn't do it
the other thing you people need to know
is that
statistically nationwide
when abusers fight for custody 70 of the
time
they get it
and new hampshire is no different in
that respect
um
it's a very hard problem
this bill
might do something about it but i i
think it does need to be amended
um
so
it's an intractable problem and it's an
attractable problem in new hampshire
courts
seeing none we'll go to the
final person on our list
thank you thank you madam chair just to
make sure can you hear me okay
yes i can excellent thank you for the
record my name is richard head i'm the
government affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch you should have received
yesterday uh written testimony from me
uh regarding this bill
um
and and i'm happy if if you ask i'm
the um the one of the primary concerns
that we have with this bill is
the conflict that this creates with the
statutory role of a guardian ad litem
which the statute of 461 a16
says is to gather information to assist
the court in determining the best
interest of the child
suspect of having a bias one way or the
other and and it's sort of an inevitable
aspect of the job and these are
typically very high conflict situations
uh in which a gal is being appointed
um and they have
there's there's a history there is
they're difficult cases um
uh to say the least
one if you if you ask the guardian of
items to start taking
what at some level even if it's a minor
level an advocacy position which is
uh
which is essentially making an
evaluation of of is violence suspected
or even alleged and this gets to to the
point that was described earlier the
mere allegation of domestic violence
would require a referral to a local
crisis center or assessment
by a domestic violence counselor
and that is not the job of the guardian
enlightenment the guardian advice job is
to assist the court to gather
information
and to provide data to the court and in
order to be able to do that
has to appear and be objective and
independent
and we have a concern that in a in a
atmosphere that is already
full of conflict
we're putting a duty on the guardian ad
litem
that may appear to one of the parties to
be a bias towards the other by referring
somebody to counseling
that is a step towards um
having a more active role in the case
itself
as opposed to that statutory role
that's described that i mentioned
earlier
and then with regard to the to the
lethality assessment in addition to
whatever confidentiality questions that
may exist as to the content of that
lethality assessment
um it does create another burden on the
gal
it does create an expense
and and really the the information that
is contained within that lethality
assessment
is a tool for the police to make a
determination on a very short-term basis
on on uh what are some risks
involved in a particular situation the
content of it is is typically if you
have a good gal the gil is going to
obtain that information anyway
and be reporting to the to the court um
you know that and more
in terms of of the information
um
so i i i think it one is not necessary
and two adds a burden and an expense to
a guardian ad litem uh and and is an
additional delay in a in a proceeding
um with that i'll i'll be happy to take
any questions and refer you to my
written testimony filed yesterday
thank you mr head i do have one question
from
thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
it was mentioned before that um
gals may be
requested by
um
applicants um
i
wanted
to see if you could um expound on that
and how often that happens and
um just
sure
so frequency i honestly don't know that
i i don't
dive into those details certainly if the
if there if there is a guardian item
that is qualified uh that party that the
parties want that is who would be
um
who would be the guardian headliner for
the case so
it does happen the frequency
that's the preference
um
but i truthfully i don't i don't um
practice in the family law and i haven't
seen sort of data on
how guardian of items ultimately are
being identified and and put into a case
but preference would be obviously if if
the
if the party select a guardian of the ad
litem that's
some level into a better route
thank you
the next question will come from
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
mr head for taking my question
you alluded
to
unintentional bias from guardian items
which i have seen
as well
in their decision-making process
you said their job is to assist the
court and gather gather data and must
appear objective
um
how often are you seeing this and how
i guess my point was as to this bill
as to this bill which would
require
the guardian litem to be the the one to
um
to direct or or to
refer i guess it's the word
the the party making the allegation or
or when the guardian item suspects it is
is taking an affirmative step which
would appear to the other side
to be taking a position which is i've
now um
you know
i've i've now i as the guardian ad
litems suspect
um that domestic violence has occurred
here
and
i'm going to take the affirmative step
of referring that person to counseling
it very well intended i'm not i'm not
saying it's not
but what i'm saying is that the other
party
who
very well may be challenging domestic
violence
is going to see that act as taking sides
certainly in the report to the court
um there is there are there's data that
that has
you know
that presents um
a view on the situation
um but the the
investigation itself and this would
really be triggered during the
investigation
um because it's if it's alleged then
there's a referral or if it's suspected
so if during the course of the
investigation itself the guardian of
item suspects domestic violence that
would
have to re require a referral and that
act is
is essentially a
an act in the midst of a
independent
and unbiased
process
so i think it's creating an opportunity
for just further
friction um in a in a difficult
situation
thank you representative altschiller do
thank you chair and uh thank you mr head
for taking my question
um i'm wondering if you could
give me your opinion as to on um
miss justina's assertion that this bill
as written could possibly breach
of a crisis center advocate and a
survivor
if this referral were to come from a gal
and then further
i guess so i don't have an opinion on
that i i don't
um
i'm trying to think it through what
would be the circumstance where that
would occur certainly if the
um
or counselor became
a witness that because you know
essentially is identified as a person
now with knowledge and a witness
that creates some conflict but i i
honestly don't i'm not sure uh i think
it's it's probably a better question for
thank you very much
great thank you
seeing no more hands and having nobody
else on the list
and no more questions i will close
um
testimony for house bill
we had 16 support
opposed
to
and we had five people testify according
to my list
and i will thank representative long for
his patience
and we will open testimony for house
this portion of test testimony with uh
representative long who i'm sure would
like to introduce his bill
thank you madam chair and i'll wait for
uh madame clerk when you're ready
uh she
put up her finger side to hang on about
it so yeah i'm trying to get to you so
quick because we're 32 minutes behind
schedule but i'll give representative
valencia all the time she needs
okay thank you i just need like a minute
in between to get the paperwork okay
i'll try to remember that okay thank you
okay so thank you madam chair uh for the
record i'm representative long uh i
represent hillsborough district 10 in
the within the city of manchester
um house bill 460
came throughout the um throughout the
years on this committee
of
trying to get our fingers on
how would this bill affect the other
cases
um
you know we you know we hear of we hear
of issues that we're looking to fix
however when we fix those issues the
following term we hear
different issues that came from that
so the study would be working with um
with the circuit court to
see if we can't
get more information when we need it a
lot of times we'll hear bills
and
we need information we're going to
execute in three days
and we just don't get that i know when i
first started on children of family law
there was a circuit court person
assigned
to us
that had all the information that we
needed even
even on information that they don't
relatively keep data of uh but they
would
they would go and look up some of the
data maybe take a 25 reading of it and
give us an example
um so that were they there we we
you know we could have a little bit of a
pulse on the bills that affect the other
cases
uh in
how it would reduce or increase
conflicts i i know myself for years on
this committee i i've always tried to
look at every bill
on the possibility of increasing
um
or or decreasing conflicts those are
something
as as a representative um i i want to be
sure i'm not passing
legislation that increases conflicts
because
that that's not what i want to do
um so this is relative to determination
of parental rights and responsibilities
um you know uh you know for example uh
bills with respect to co-parenting
you know how many are there um you know
how how difficult is this you know i
mean i
suspect that there are a lot of
co-parenting issues um but i don't know
that it's just what i guess from talking
to constituents or whatever and that may
not be the case um so
although this this is
with respect to determining parental
rights and responsibilities you know
have we heard as we heard today
um
you know there's a lot of questions that
we have and you know i'm grateful for mr
head being here
um
you know because that is also helpful to
have a representative here but
uh to you know to to work with the
circuit court to see if we can't come up
with a way
to get
uh in my mind some imperative
information with respect to decision
making that we have in this in this
committee to you know not only
help us to make informed decisions
but to relieve the circuit court of
you know of of issues that they have in
judging
you know i mean i'm sure they would much
rather have it clear and concise then
you know because what happens is other
you know judges deter you know judges
determine different
um you know read the law differently and
so
you know we've heard over time where you
know one couple you know one parent will
come in
with an issue
where another judge in another court
totally took that differently um so
you know
helping both the circuit court and
children of family law
come together with a um
you know with with a uh conclusive
uh informed decisions for us and a
better managed
um circuit court for them is why this
thank you madam chair
thank you representative long i have one
hand up for one question well now i have
two
representative belanger you have a
question
i do madam chair and thank you
representative long for taking this
question
um
i see
the three members of the house of
representatives appointed by the speaker
and two members of the senate appointed
by the senate president
um
when taking into consideration
establishing this bill that would
establish a committee
um did you take into consideration
judges
as i feel they may imply a good
uh excuse me they may be able to provide
well committees that normally uh thank
you for the question uh uh
representative blander
committees are normally uh legislatures
um the senate more than likely is gonna
say one member
you know um
so it's usually legislatures on
committees and commissions then you
would invite every i mean the commission
would be great if we could even invite
fam you know
parents that have been involved um but i
think
i you know i think that's on a broader
base uh but with respect to uh parental
rights and responsibilities i think um
you know i think the legislature
um
you know
i know
mr head will sit with us i know
uh judge um
judge king is it uh would sit with us
um you know you know because it it it'll
help both of us then it'll help them as
thank you um representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
it's my understanding thus far this
session that um people are
uh
not willing to establish committees that
are going to uh report
this year
due to the lack of
um ability to meet in person uh this
year
and um it seems like this is also a
perennial issue so
it seemed that you would be in favor of
creating this more of a standing
commission to
you know hear issues
uh in the
family court would you
um
would you be amenable to an amendment
such such as that
uh so thank you for the question uh
representative keller um i i'm not privy
to what's
you know
what's gonna make it or not gonna make
it so maybe you could have your people
call my people and we could uh
um so but i i you know i think a
commission
i mean this was
when when i put this in it was parental
rights and responsibility only i figured
i'd take a bite instead of going after
the whole pitcher um so i mean a
commission i you know commission would
take longer i think i i i think this is
going to be relatively
um simple and expedited because you know
the circuit court knows what they want
and the legislator knows what they want
um so it's just a matter of where we're
going to compromise and get it done so
uh but yeah a commission
i i mean i'm open to whatever the
committee thinks would be in the best
interests of uh the family court and
thank you
and then we will move on to
um
one more person wants to testify
uh mr richard head
mr head go ahead
great thank you madam chair members of
the committee my name is richard head
i'm the government affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch we take no
position on this bill
i just wanted to offer two things one
i've only been on this job since
november but
you should uh in in hearing what
representative long said always feel
free to use me as a resource if you need
data
um preferably before a hearing
i can ask people to extract data out of
our odyssey database if it exists
or
get you know more general information
from people with experience so one i
just offer to the extent without regard
to what happens on this bill
if it passes or doesn't pass feel free
to use me as a resource if you need data
um and i'm i'm happy to do that
secondly the covit has has affected sort
of normal processes i think normally um
the judicial branch and and depending on
the committees
um there's usually a introduction and
and discussion of of issues and topics
at the beginning of of the first
year of a of a session
um and that didn't happen this this year
and i think it's incredibly productive
and useful
um and maybe if this bill does not go
forward um
and if there are in-person meetings
going on at the beginning of next
session maybe there'll be a delayed
opportunity to to do that with this
committee
but other than that i'd be happy to
i see none thank you and at this point i
will close the hearing
on house bill 460
and thank you all for your perseverance
and your assistance and your help today
i hope tomorrow will go a lot smoother i
got it i think
so thank you all get some rest be ready
for lots of work tomorrow like you were
today
and we'll see madam chair are we
expecting to execute bills uh tomorrow
we're not okay
thank you
you're very welcome
madam chair mr head has his hand raised
again i'm not sure if that's on purpose
or on accident i'm sorry mr head
uh representative all chiller did you
have a question or comment
oh i just said well done madam chair
thank you
well thank you
thank you all
see you all tomorrow have a good
afternoon if you're driving anywhere be
you